can I just really quick you feel freee
to cut this I love watching you work I
love showing up to meet somebody that I
am a fan of already and I've seen their
astronomical rise to success and then I
see why they deserve it why just
watching you operate for the past like 5
10 minutes has been fascinating how so
you just care so much about what you're
doing and you're meticulous but not in a
way that's micromanaging and annoying
and the attention to detail is like very
intense but not in a way that's too far
you know right amount of autism it's the
perfect amount of Asbergers I don't know
what word we're supposed to be using
right now but it's not lateral moves
it's actually improving things cuz
sometimes you'll just watch people make
arbitrary lateral changes for no reason
just to like throw their dick around or
boss someone around or something it's
been like really very endearing to watch
thank you I appreciate that it's really
nice to meet you you too uh Travis Kelce
we just saw on the TV outside we did
fizer advert but I guess if you're
hanging out the back of Taylor Swift
what do you care you know what I mean I
yeah well okay so we just saw what what
happened to you when you saw that it's
just kind of it's so strange to see
someone that has so much status and kind
of embodies a lot of like rebellious
nature which I think you know football
players QB's that like Alpha masculine
thing fisa I mean fisa's brand Equity
it's like it's it's hardly cool what's
the price what's the price that makes it
worth it what's the price to someone
like Travis Kelce that makes it worth it
for guys like you to go oh come on you
got domed by a Pharma company one Taylor
Swift
[__] so here's the [__] do you
think dating her is what influenced him
to do it get being attracted to girls
that skinny as a vaccine
injury you were saying before we got
started that there's been a a big push
body positivity we need diversity Barbie
movie comes out and Taylor Swift makes a
billion dollars on tour it's like it's
just [__] Germany girls are back
thank god dream um no I so here's a real
[__] conspiracy right the real
conspiracy
is Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift's
relationship was orchestrated by big
farmer because they started dating at
the same time that he did that fisa
campaign so search volume for Travis
Kel's name went through the roof and
when you search for his name the vaccine
stuff and the fiser partnership com up
too so my question about that it's like
my same thing about aliens and stuff is
like I just think people are so weak and
so desperate to like talk to a girl at a
bar or get attention or the wrong person
involved in that Scandal took Edibles
don't you think someone would have
gotten fired and told people about it oh
right it's like with aliens it's like
someone would have snitched someone one
some guy would have gotten drunk at a
bar and been like hey like you don't
want to go home with me you want to see
a picture of a [__] alien you know
what I'm saying like don't you think it
would have gotten
out yeah I mean coordination is
difficult and there's definitely Two
Worlds that people are able to hold in
their mind at once which is the
government is both so incompetent that
they can't organize a piss up in a
brewery and so competent that they're
able to orchestrate this sort of I go to
DMV and I'm like if they were aliens we
would have known okay like we would
absolutely know by now well maybe the
beginning and end of their capability is
orchestrating a Travis Kelsey Taylor
Swift relationship I don't know it's
weird I also think though you know who's
who's she gonna date that's the thing
who's she gonna date he it seems like
guys will date down all day you know but
girl who's she gonna date who's the
Jay-Z to her Beyonce yeah rough one I uh
do you know meat Canyon he does
illustration videos on the internet
really really great guy and I thought
you were talking about my my childbirth
thing come on come on I'm sorry I'm
sorry two and a half minutes in and
talking about your meat Canyon anyway
he's got a channel called Papa meat and
on it he reacted to Swifty Tik toks and
it was girls um crying breaking down
crying because they The Ticket Master
website had shut down after they've been
waiting for six hours okay great um
there was this one where it broke down
the finances I think Taylor Swift's
already beaten Michael Jackson for the
most revenue generated from a tour ever
it's I think at the moment okay 3/4 of a
billion dollars this tour is lasting for
nearly two years it's monstrous okay
well she's done a genius thing she's got
kids and I I'm she kids her fans her
fans sorry she's not a mother but she
appeals to children in a way that I
think so many and I'm sure we'll wait
into this territory in some capacity
where so many female pop stars it's all
about being hypersexualized
hypersexualized and like you know I'm
having a a boy when I you know have a
kid but it's like there's certain you're
like I can't let my kid watch I can't
let my kid listen to this she's done
this genius thing where not only that
have you seen her dancing I actually
when I get into the conspiracy theories
you know I think she's very mindful
about not being too overtly sexual dials
that back the way that if you look at
how she dances she's like bad at dancing
it's not sexy it's like awkward she
looks like one of those Balloon Man
outside of a car dealership waving
inflatable flailing CH she kind of just
is like sort of awkward and weird
there's never any sexuality about it
there's never any singing about sex it's
always just like getting your
heartbroken and these kind of relatively
teenage feelings and I think she's done
a really like genius job of that well I
think in a world of Sam Smith wearing
nipple tassels and dressing as the devil
the the original cult culture is the
counterculture right like if you want to
predict the future what you should do is
look at a movement that's happening now
that hasn't had the inverse happen yet
because every culture requires the equal
and opposite thing right it's like the
thermodynamics of [__] culture so um
2020 everyone's shut down no one can go
outside 2021 Megan D stallion does hot
girl summer which is last year you
weren't able to be your free self this
year get with your girlfriends and do
your hair and do your makeup wet ass
[__] was around that time too maybe
they could have come together and then
the year after that they did feral girl
summer so you had hot girl summer and
then and feral girl summer was uh you
know don't shave don't brush your hair
wear slouchy sweatpants don't bother
with boys yeah for every cult that has
to be counterculture and if you've got
Sam Smith doing his thing you know
Taylor Swift looks like a [__]
conservative icon this comparatively and
then I think that's part of the reason I
mean country music is also so big
because country music for the most part
is it's kind of like older women they're
wearing like boots and pants you know or
and then you have Katy Perry with like
cupcakes on her tits you know it's kind
of like um I think country music in
general parents feel safe for letting
their kids listen to it and going to
shows it's a little more innocent yeah
but what's the worst thing that's going
to happen you're going to be an
alcoholic and and get in a car wreck in
a truck and yeah and yeah and a man
might wear a square toe boot which is a
big problem for me that's a large yeah I
mean I see that a lot in in Austin Texas
yeah but yeah the um this meat counting
video Papa on his second Channel Papa
meat he's reacting to all of these
things and she I didn't know but she
released a movie in cinemas oh yeah yeah
yeah girls are losing their [__]
minds with these um bracelets no like a
baton like an LED thing waving it around
and then the credits were rolling and
girls were holding hands dancing in a
circle underneath the [__] screen it
is they're losing their mind I I mean I
didn't know she's are Star Wars they
have little
lightsabers that's true this is Star
Wars for girls but she also is very it's
these very easy to understand like girl
boss anthems you know what I mean and
something she did do that cuz I I've you
don't know that much about her like
music per se I've worked with a bunch of
people that are obsessed with her she
does write all of her own stuff which is
very cool she's not one of these like
industry plants where she's got 15
writers and you go you know she really
does write it herself um and seems like
she plays all the music herself and she
the way that she engages her fans she
makes them feel really special I feel
like this is something we can learn from
you do an amazing job at engaging your
fans but like she leaves little little
Easter eggs for them and she like really
thinks her albums out in a way and
leaves these like puzzle pieces for them
and these codes and sends gifts to fans
if they've come to a certain amount of
shows like she's really like done this
marketing thing that I think a lot of us
would think is kind of like corny and I
would I'd be embarrassed like I'd be
like oh if you like me you like me if
you don't you don't I'm not gonna send
I'm not going to do a mailing list it's
like oh she did like what Tim Ferris did
she like built up a mailing list and
engaged with her fans and like and was
okay with going I want this really badly
like she was okay with being like I want
to be really famous and successful it
wasn't like if you like me you like me
if you don't you don't you know as a way
to control if I get rejected at least it
wasn't you know my idea but she did this
one thing where she got called a snake
because she um I don't know what it was
there was like all these snake emojis
either someone cheated on someone and
some kind of like you know Taylor swiv
gossip and someone asked her in an
interview they said so what do you feel
about the fact that so many people
online call you a snake and she went
well snakes eat
rats and I was like that's pretty
gangster like I see why girls like look
up to her every time people come for her
manages to sublimate it into something
else I think Elon Musk did something
similar where he got popped for getting
one of his staff at SpaceX or Tesla
pregnant and he just reacted to the
Tweet by saying the the world's birth
rates are declining I need to do my bit
like the [__] Brazilian
jiu-jitsu lexical [__] trickery that
you've just done there she stunts on
every time they come for her she stunts
on them somehow and I think so much of
our job is forward- facing people now is
figuring out how to handle haters or
like how not respond or you not respond
at all you know but you can't too much
but she just kind of owns it and then
she'll put it into her songs I think wit
is such an underrated skill just being
able to be witty with with stuff and you
can be charming and not give it too much
attention interesting that look at this
the [__] Taylor Swift podcast one
like definitely an interesting lesson
there about the fact that she was
prepared to
do things that other artists of even a
smaller size would feel might be beneath
them or might be like low state
it's what I think in the psychology
literature would be called a counter
signal so um if you look at CEOs now
they'll happily wear Crocs or sneakers
or whatever and a hoodie into the office
but the guy who's a middle manager
that's desperately climbing he'll have
to wear a three-piece suit of course so
it's almost like she can afford to do
this because of her excess um we were
talking outside you mentioned about uh
like are you supposed to have a take on
the Ukraine I think you on Joe's show
yesterday and it's like wow there's so
many people listening like I supposed to
talk about something important do you
feel that you know is there a an
obligation if you get to a certain size
of having to talk about important things
and and stuff like that can you not just
keep having fun all the way up I think
for me it's like being a comedian I
think it's really important to you know
know our place you know I think for me
it's like as long as the take is funny
it doesn't matter you can talk about
anything you know but to come in and be
one of these like Hollywood people not
that I see myself as someone who's in
Hollywood I think a lot of people might
see me that way I can't ser L go this is
who you should vote for or this is how
you should think or this is what you
should believe or this is or take the
moral High ground but if the take has
some sort of comedic value it's like
there's nothing we can't talk about I
like to stay away from politics for the
most part unless I'm making fun of both
sides simultaneously that's because I
think people I think it's our job as
Comedians and and uh podcasters is to
surprise people there's just so much
content out there right now and so many
people are talking about politics and I
think you got to go like what kind of
person is seeking comedy they are maybe
bored at their jobs they they want to
take a girl on a date they they have
their kid at home crying they've been in
a long marriage they just want to go to
a club they want to go to a venue and
hear something different from what
they're seeing online all day and so
it's my job to surprise them so if they
show up and I'm going to start talking
about Trump they're like I just had to
hear my uncle yell about this for two
hour like you just I just have to do
whatever the opposite everybody else is
doing to try to give them some kind of
surprise yeah it's uh it's strange to
think about
how as people's platform grow there
there's this compulsion to have a take
on on everything and unless you have a
take no one else is saying there's
really no need to speak about it yeah
unless you're unbelievably educated in
something but I I definitely as as
platforms grow there's a there's almost
a pressure to be like well [__] I
better talk about something interesting
here well in talking about platforms
growing it's like you can play the long
short game the long game and for me like
I mean you know knowing Rogan for so
long and seeing that like his EP his
first thousand episodes were just him
and his friends just talking about
[__] talking about you know comedy
and stuff it wasn't necessarily what was
going on in the news and then that made
for this library that was really easy to
Syndicate you can go back and listen to
episodes of his from 10 years ago still
funny still entertaining I always like
in terms of making the podcast I always
want to go like I want to build this
Library that's Evergreen and not too
topical so if people discover my podcast
now and they start from the beginning
it's still going to be about you know
main themes of human nature
relationships making mistakes
edification all the kind of stuff that
you talk about too that's a little bit
evergreed
they I always think about this so bench
a good example I listened to a lot of
him during uh covid because if there's a
rapidly changing news cycle and you've
got [__] all else to do someone that
does one episode 5 days a week that is
always telling you what's happened in
the last 24 hours is pretty good place
to go but I realized looking back on
that no one's going back to hear what
happened on April 20th 2020 because it
was so you get this huge lift off in
terms of interest but it doesn't
necessarily carry through which I think
is yeah is an interesting way to kind of
look at things if people go like oh my
God I just discovered you know modern
wisdom he just had Jordan Peterson on oh
my God he had Jordan Peterson on two
years ago go let me listen to that
they're going to cover different stuff
like oh my and I just learned so much he
had Robert Green on you know so for me I
I really you know I come from making TV
and sitcoms and when you try to make
sitcoms that get syndicated the idea is
that they live forever you know so if
you have jokes that are too topical you
know they're going to expire and it's
going to feel dated so I always kind of
thought like okay what's my place in
this podcast space because there's a lot
of really really smart people doing this
there are a lot of people way more
qualified than me talking about politics
that's not you know something I
necessarily am qualified to weigh in on
I can make jokes about it but why don't
I do these like Evergreen shows that
people can on road trips just go back
two years and it's still going to be
relevant have you been happy to see the
Jada pinket Smith meltdown because the
bar for being a good mother is now being
being set lower than ever I love that
she's like Will Smith and I have not
been married for seven years and I am J
pet Smith Smith it's like then why are
you Jada pick it all of a sudden why is
your book say Smith on the end um that
whole thing is wild to me and I've been
actually thinking about this podcast
because I've been a little bit nervous
about coming on it and how I can be like
useful in some way to your listeners and
because they all seem to be very high
performing striving people and you know
I do have this theory that you know and
it's probably something you've explored
before is that like who you marry or
date is a business decision you know not
in terms of we're going into business
together but in terms of the amount of
bandwidth you have you know the amount
of energy you have is this person
energizing you is it depleting you it's
going to decide how focused you can be
in your personal life like one of my
favorite quotes is the flow Bear quote
um be uh what is it be organized and
orderly in your no be regular and
orderly in your personal life so you can
be original and violent in your work you
know so have like not it doesn't have to
be boring not boring sex you have to be
bor of your partner but it the most
stressful part of your day should be
work right so I think that oftentimes
the person you choose is a business
decision but I look at them and I'm like
they just wanted to build a business you
know I think that was always kind of a
business arrangement in my opinion I
watched the first ever time that I've
seen the rock on a podcast and he was on
Trevor Noah's podcast which he's
partnered with Spotify and I didn't know
this but The Rock has broken up with his
wife but is still business partners with
her so they have a daughter together
okay and The Rock and his ex-wife are
now separated but still business
partners and still have the daughter for
his business like his zoa maybe or the
[__] tequila or what the rum whatever
it is that he just I don't know what but
at least one of them he's still business
partners with his with his wife there's
a lot of these things where it's like
you make that kind of money together and
then it's like we're better together as
a business I mean think about what would
it would be like having to like break up
a corporation basically you know a
divorce is easier than a a separation of
the business totally but yeah I I it's
not for me I'm one of those idiots that
still wants to have like amazing sex
with someone and like really feel like
I'm best friends with my person and I'm
going to like hold out for that cut to
me in 10 years when I'm married to Bill
Gates or some crazy Craven [__] Y and
I'm like I'm like we own half of the
McDonald's potatoes and the GMOs or
whatever
but I I I guess that's for some people
but you know I don't know I really that
to me seems really Sinister and Craven I
mean you know look I'm a comic I'm happy
to way I didn't say what happened to the
Oscars when you know Will Smith smacked
Chris Rock in the face you know that was
and no one stood up by the way no nobody
even stood up like that's you know as a
comedian people you know are like God
you guys can get away with anything
until you get punched in the face in
front of you know room of thousand
people that don't even stand up to help
you but the fact that he looked back at
her did that in the name of his wife I'm
like I don't know what videos she has on
him I don't know what photo I don't know
what the [__] is going on in there what
kind of who's Afraid of Virginia wolf
[__] is going on in that marriage but
that's my nightmare yeah do you know uh
Ryan long and Danny from The Boys cast
yes yeah in New York uh they I was
texting him they did a really great
episode a couple of weeks ago about this
and I was texting Ryan and he was like
dude I'm I'm unironically really [__]
worried about Will Smith like genuinely
[__] emotionally seen the video where
she was filming him and he was like I
need you to stop filming me and she's
like yes that's a while ago now right
yeah but the his fa I mean she's like
he's in a bad mood and she's like this
is my business this is what I I'm on
camera for a living I'm not getting paid
brok Broken Man scary but there are some
men that I've seen this before where
some men are like I just need this mom
swife to like keep me together to keep
me focused I don't know I think when you
get famous at a very young age maybe you
become infantilized or frozen or you
cling to to someone that feels like a
safety net to you fix you cuz then you
also get to this place where it's like
you know my wish for guys like you is
that you get all the things you want and
all the Big Brand deals and all the huge
products and but don't get Target on
your back famous because when you get
stat famous you're like well if I go
like date a waitress is this going to be
a lawsuit like is this a night is am I
going to get accused of harassment like
when you get to a certain point as a man
in terms of getting famous I think it's
for women too it just looks a little bit
different go from Predator to prey I saw
a really interesting reel from uh Chris
to Stephano I can't remember whose show
he was on but he was talking about his
dad had given him a piece of advice his
dad sounds like an absolute Maniac Mafia
dude yeah sounds like an absolute Maniac
by the way and uh he was saying uh maybe
maybe Chris had become single or maybe
it was before he' had his kids I don't
know and he was saying uh you're
sleeping with all of these women and uh
you're having all of this fun and you
know for every hundred women 99 of them
are going to be great but there's one
that's going to [__] ruin your life
and I don't know what the proportion is
but there's definitely you know from
men's side in a post me too World there
is a different tenor to what's going on
there is this fear that's out there and
I don't disagree that you know a lot of
me too was necessary to kind of counter
some very predatory men that were using
their position and their power to gain
sexual access in a way that wasn't
ethical the problem is when that
overreaches and goes from trying to uh
sanitize the bad elements of male
behavior and instead it just sterilizes
all of it and everyone's like [__]
terrified and working on tenter hooks
and it seems like that you know that
Chris story kind of alludes to that it's
like there's there's a [__] Minefield
out there and you got to be careful why
you well I do know in my business it's
backfired majorly in terms of you know
that less people were hiring women for a
long time because they're like I don't
want a woman in my office are you insane
and then they people started putting
glass offices in you know like glass
walls like this would have been glass
just so everyone sees what's going in
here
I would go on mov sets and people would
be like you know I was I did a a Foo
Fighters movie and there was a sex scene
in it and they were like but you don't
have to you can you know wear your shirt
if you want I'm like this is a sex scene
you guys I'm like but whatever you need
and I was like why are you Lu I'm not
going to sue you
guys I mean I'm like I'm a female
comedian on the list of [__] that's
happened to me this is like you know so
I just I found myself being like Oh God
everyone is like terrified because I
mean yes there were a lot of and look
yes I'm sure you could do friends on the
fact that why women are so desperate
that they got to a point where they
needed to sue someone because they were
hugged too long at a Christmas party or
what maybe that's a mental illness or
maybe that's childhood trauma or
whatever it is why do women feel the
need to be grifters and to take
advantage that's you know talk to a you
know sociologist about that but you know
it's been um it's been really
interesting though one side effect I've
really kind of uh found fascinating is
that younger guys kind of want to date
older girls you said that you've never
been hit on more than what your
fertility has been on front front for
the people that are listening Whitney is
heavily pregnant 3 weeks away from
popping yes because if I said like Chris
harass me they' be like no you [__]
you're obviously what's like what do you
think it is why just a big billboard for
your fertility what is I think there's I
think there's a couple things I think
and this is something we've texted about
I don't know why comedians have to do
this where we can't just go into
something without going and we've texted
about that like I don't want the
audience give the well it's in between
all of the nudes that you keep on
sending me finally got the that's
supposed to be on the confide app um so
I think that for me and I think a lot of
women are struggling this right with
this right now um
or I don't know if they're struggling
with it but I think that they're
striving to struggle with it I'll get
there I think I came off so tough and so
hard for so long I think this kind of
just softened me in a way that made and
sort of you know I spent so much of my
career like trying to be one of the guys
or kind of try to come off like I wasn't
a girl so that they wouldn't you know
try to flirt with me at work or so that
I would get respect or so that I could
go on stage and command respect from the
audience and not show any
vulnerabilities and um I grew up with a
mother who and you know many people
women of that generation were who was
like I mean there's no other way to say
it she was a gold digger you know she
had to date men for money and it drove
me nuts like were men in the house that
were just that you have to wear this and
you have to and I would have to go to
dinners with her and like behave so that
I wouldn't mess it up for her and you
know it was kind of very high stake
situation her appearance was everything
and you know back then that was your
currency and I just remember going I'm
never going to do this like this is it's
disrespectful to myself it's disrespect
I just wanted to be self-sufficient kind
of before I started dating anybody
because I never wanted to be thinking
about the amount of money they were
making or I never wanted them to have to
take care of me it was just like too
embarrassing you know and so I think
that I work so hard to be independent
and that's what I talked about my
standup and so I think that by the time
I got pregnant people were kind of like
oh like she does have vulnerability she
does have a softness to her and I think
a lot of women right now are afraid to
show that side of ourselves you know and
I think that there's a lot of strength
in vulnerability and there's a lot of
strength in showing a soft quote
feminine side but right now everyone's
trying to like come off so tough and I'm
one of the guys that it's just sort of
like I don't think you realize that
that's actually weakening you in a lot
of ways why do you think they're trying
to do that what do you think they're
trying to get out of it what do you
think's the reason there's a couple
things I think for me I'll be a little
bit specific like you know I I had a dad
that wanted boys like you know that it
was for a very young age I was just kind
of you know treated like a boy it was
all about how successful I could be at
sports it was all about how good my
grades could be my dad would wake me up
in the middle of the night and quiz me
on spelling work you know it was all
about getting achievements um and there
was an awkwardness about my femininity
um and then you know played Sports was
rewarded for for being tough became a
you know female comic sort of had to
neuter myself in a lot of ways you know
that's my specific thing but I think
that you know women I think you know I
think there's like there's a lot going
on but I think that for me personally I
wanted so badly to just succeed in my
career without anyone thinking that I
was sleeping around or flirting or using
my looks to get ahead because the last
thing that you would want would be oh
she shagged her way to the top of the
totem
pole so I just always wanted to be like
kind of extra hard and sort of extra
bulld dyy pum just kind of like I'm one
of the guys so that no one would ever
flirt with me so there would never be
rumors around that I was like sleeping
my way or getting anything that I didn't
deserve yeah you know so I think I
overcompensated a little bit um I think
I was scared um of you know having any
vulnerability so I pretended to be
tougher than I was yeah um I think there
was that I think you're kind of taught
at a young age being a girl is a
weakness it's not a strength that's what
I was taught you know it was like you go
on the playground and the boys they let
go play and the girls they go be careful
you're going to hurt yourself you're
going to rip your tights you know that's
like pounded into us at a very early
agees you're more delicate um you're
weak and I always wanted to like no I'm
not I wanted to help my dad you know I
want to get on the ladder and help him
fix the roof and was like no you don't
get to do that your brother gets to do
that you know so I think for me I felt
like I had so much to prove um you know
and and then I think that you know just
fear in insecurity you know and I think
that a lot of times when you know you I
was very ambitious and I'm very about
that and I think I thought I had to sort
of just come off really tough so that
people took me seriously are you seeing
a new potential advantage of embodying
the vulnerable the feminine is this the
new competitive advantage that you think
think so I really think it is you know I
think that again this is probably easy
for me to say because I have
accomplished a lot of my goals you know
I there's a strong argument to say that
what I did worked you know that I could
go in a room full of a bunch of
Executives and there's three men there
and two women there and whatever energy
I came in it didn't threaten the women
cuz I wasn't like using flirting or I
wasn't you know using feminine
advantages or whatever that would look
like like I always wanted to make sure
women liked me especially in audiences
you know and and curating that audience
um so it maybe it worked there's an
argument you know to say that it did and
now is the perfect time to kind of be
soft and show that side of myself but I
think that I did have to you know acrew
a certain amount of success in order to
give myself permission to be able to be
feminine and be soft talk to me about
that transition because I don't know I
think if I was to make a prediction over
the next 10 years I think that we're
going to see uh maybe I would put a
little B down that we're going to see a
flip and that male body dysmorphia is
already on track to overtake female body
dysmorphia within about 10 to 15 years
fascinating but I think that the crisis
from an identity perspective is going to
be on women not on men I think we have a
crisis of masculinity at the moment but
I think burbling below the surface is
going to be a crisis of femininity I
think that I would like to think that
the guys are going to be okay I can't do
as much for the girls so I'm unable to
put my finger on the pulse but I would
say that uh men are maybe going to be
much more concerned about appearance and
girls are going to be much more
concerned about identity but talk to me
about that transition of going from
being hard Brash to now having to kind
of you soften up and and allow that and
cuz I also like I you know I grew up in
a home that was very rough I mean your
English I mean maybe you know isn't it
kind of that's how his takings in our
blood yeah right like mockery and
sarcasm and roasting each other there
was a lot of passive aggressive [__]
there was a lot of alcoholism there was
a lot of you know really deep-seated
shame and biting [__] so you know by
the time I got out in the world that's
also just kind of like how I thought I
had to you know talk to people I thought
that was normal um and being around male
Comics all the time you know uh rough
roughs you up a little bit as well so I
had a hard time turning it off like in
relationships and such um but I'm sorry
I what what is the question oh how it's
transition yeah how did you find you've
got you've had to go from being that
person who is playing the masculine role
in some ways like the masculine feminine
role which is in like even over tuning
your masculinity and now you're like
okay and now I've got to like care about
this got three weeks to be to become a
[__] mother you know it's interesting
because it's like my brain gets like a
little bit scrambled around this because
you know in terms of masculine qualities
and feminine qualities it's like it's
it's I conflate them sometimes because
I'm like a lot of the qualities that I
have used thus far that I think see
masculine have been like I've been
nurturing I've just nurtured my career
you know what I mean it's like I treated
my career that you know like a child or
how I should treat a husband or
something and now I'm kind of you know I
would I would nurture other Comics I
would nurture the writers that I worked
with you know I was like I've always
kind of had that but I never really
turned it towards myself or towards a
relationship so now I'm kind of going I
think the main switch for me is that now
that I have achieved my goals I can turn
that energy onto a child and a
relationship I was very clear in my 20s
that I was not ready to attract the man
that I wanted that if he came along he
would not be he would not be down you
know so I was very much in my 20s I was
like I need to become the person that I
would want the guy that I want to be
with that they would actually be
interested in I think that's a pretty
noble way to look at developing yourself
generally I've got a friend David Perell
uh who is still I think he's been with
his Ms for girlfriend uh for two years
or so and he's [__] botted with her
like absolutely in love with her and uh
I went for lunch with him when I first
moved to Austin about 18 months ago and
we sit down and he's super successful
and he's got this big online business
and he does loads of stuff and he's
helping people's lives to be better
becoming better writers online yeah and
uh he said uh know what I realized spent
most of my 30s making myself into the
dad that my future kids want it's like
wow that that's [__] cool I love that
like even though he didn't have the
relationship he didn't have the kids now
I mean love and that honeymoon period of
a relationship uh will do all manner of
crazy things to someone's mindset so who
knows that he's not just in like a oyos
fever dream um but yeah he said that and
I was like that's really lovely and kind
of doing the same thing of turning
yourself slowly over time into the
person that the partner you want to be
within future would be attracted to
seems like a cool thing and it's like
the idea that you know like I want to
have my [__] together I didn't want to
be some mess that he had to clean up
even though a lot of you guys love a
mess and I get a little frustrated
sometimes because there's times where
you know the meat guys that I'm talking
to and they're like and then my last
girlfriend this and I have to get her
and she I'm still paying for a therapy
and then I'm still and I'm like I might
not be crazy enough like if you need to
clean up a mess like I'm not your person
I tried so hard to have my [__] together
so the by time a man came along I didn't
seem like a hassle or like it didn't
feel like I was their daughter or some
weird [__] um and uh you know but I I do
think that like you know I had a
situation where both my parents were
sick um they both had Strokes very young
so my entire like late 20s and 30s they
were in beds and I was like you know
what parenting doesn't start when you
have a kid like you should start
parenting your kids when you're in your
20s start taking care of yourself so
your kids don't have to take care of you
when they're in their 20s so I started
thinking like that at a very young age
and I started going like being a wife
doesn't start when you meet your guy
like let me start that now let me not
have a bunch of like weird exes around
let me not have a bunch of like let me
just start taking care of myself and not
having a bunch of messes that they have
to clean up and a bunch of weirdo guys
that are going to be you know I always
like thought that way very early on
there's something I had this
conversation with uh the director of
relationship science at hinge and uh she
wrote a book really interesting lady wow
and um she was saying maybe related to
that you know people find and you do
this with friends too you meet someone
you're like oh my God we've got such a
connection there's such a spark here but
what you don't realize is that person's
Sparky with everybody it's just called
like really really overtuned charm or
Charisma yeah which is usually a red
flag it's a copy mechanism well it could
be [__] anything but it's not you
that's special necessarily that's not to
say that sparks don't exist some people
do come together but a lot of the times
like okay is this person like this with
me because of me or do they do it to the
Barista that serves them the coffee and
the parking attendant that helps them
with their ticket like are they just you
know causing this all over the place
yeah that's really interesting one I
mean that brings up something that
really bothers me when I see online or
like hear girls be like he love bombed
me and then I didn't hear from it's like
or he just liked you and you got whack
and then he stopped you know or you know
or is it this pathological thing of what
you're talking about where someone comes
in and tries to like razzled Dazzle
people and their thing defitely there's
definitely something alluring about
aloofness again just you know it doesn't
need to be about relationships
friendships there is something where
you're someone that's too Keen with
anything like you call them AO it's like
dude come on stop texting stop stop
calling stop doing whatever um but if
it's the right person is it cringy I
don't know what causes two people to
become intertwined romantically or you
know socially or whatever a lot of
different ways that can happen but
there's definitely a a way that you can
make yourself more or less alluring by
you know not just being present all the
[__] time yeah right uh if there's
someone coming along this is definitely
something I've realized since how do you
say like socially batting above my
average over the last few years and
constantly being in rooms with people
I'm like Jesus [__] Christ like hold
it together hold it together um as
that's happened the best thing that I've
learned is just to like leave the room
or say goodbye or say fewer things than
you think that you need to interesting
um and I've definitely noticed that with
myself as like people's behavior has
changed at least a little bit over the
last couple of years to me as they now
start to see whatever the [__] they
think they see which is to me just still
like this weird guy from Britain uh but
their behavior changed and I also notice
that when someone's like you know they
use brevity in their brief and they hey
man just wa to say whatever whatever and
then they're off you're like yeah that
guy's nice opposed to that it's a little
bit H I wish I you this podcast existed
when I was in my 20s because I was the
cringiest and uh you're making me think
of some of the most successful people
allow others to project on to them so
what you mean just say as little as
possible and let people just project on
someone start with the fact that someone
already likes you right and then it's
all downhill from there the more you try
to over talk or over apologize or
control them you know look look at your
motives of what you're saying and why
you're saying it hey how are you good to
see you if that's just all it is hey are
you okay do you need anything then it
just turns into being unctuous then it
just turns into you're trying to make
them like you and people feel it like
people feel that energy that desperate
predatory energy and like Paris Hilton
fascinates me because she will say as
little as possible publicly and she just
allows us to project onto her she
doesn't Beyonce never speak once you
never hear her speak she's done a couple
interviews she's done Oprah here and
there she did a documentary but she says
as little as possible Adam Sandler
doesn't do interview I mean uh Leonardo
DiCaprio doesn't do interviews and has
someone that just talks for a living
there's times like where I we try to
you've already kind of said everything
you need to say now you're just confused
people trying to control them
micromanage them or just fill space cuz
you're nervous yeah
that's the space for people to kind of
show you who they are or what they are
no matter who it is right in the [__]
person on the street or the person
that's ringing
you
definitely thinking
about thinking about what happens when
someone tries too hard to
be not forthcoming but they're like
pliable in a way uh and I think this is
fundamentally why simps uh simpy
Behavior amongst men in particular is so
it causes even in men and some women
apart from the women that are benefiting
from it it causes so much sort of
aversion and and discomfort because
there's a sense that if this person is
this pliable with this
girl what is there to say that they're
not just going to you know sneaky [__]
syndrome I think it's referred to in uh
biology where the it's a slip streaming
effect where like the Lesser male will
try and do sneaky [__] to try and like
get access sexual access to uh females
and yeah there's something about being
super super pliable that makes someone
feel unreliable like you want to know
that your friend even if they're your
best friend has limits yes because if
they just continue to fold and it's like
okay so where are you if I just keep
digging and digging and digging do I hit
anything solid or do I just come out the
the side of you because you will
continue to fold around me that's not
what you want from a friend that's not
what you'd want from a partner it's not
what you'd want from a parent it's not
what you'd want from a member of your
community you would want someone who is
courteous but firm right like here's my
here's my boundaries and I'm going to
care about you up until the point at
which you get to something that
appropriates like my limit there was
this um I actually learned a lot about
my own energy and like probably what I
give off on like dates or this or that
cuz sometimes when I try to go like
don't try too hard don't try too hard to
that's the thing about trying to be soft
or whatever like you know I can't I I
can't like try to be like sometimes I'll
come off like silly I'm like just just
be who you are I I know I already have
like an intense energy about me I I do
actually if anyone um is looking for
some kind of way to you know look in the
mirror about your energy eoin therapy is
a miracle and there's ways to do it
where you don't have to own a horse you
know hang on hang on hang
on or just work with prey and animal in
fck knew right you knew we were are you
talking to horses you're not talking to
horses basically being around horses are
because they're prey animals and they're
herd animals their only reward is
Serenity any other emotion besides
complete Serenity boils down to fear so
if you're truly doing echoine therapy
with a horse that's not been you know
broken that doesn't have a bit on or a
bridal where it's being forced to be
near you it will choose to be near you
only if you're emanating complete
Serenity and being present in the moment
so if you're next to a horse and you're
like like why I got to take a picture
because I wanted to that just boils down
to fear to them so they're just like I
feel fear is there a they walk away is
there a mountain lion yeah they start to
go like well I got to take it there's a
problem right hang on so can you go to a
ranch that will do therapy with horses
is there such a thing as a therapy horse
yes absolutely is this like a [__]
whatever it is emotional support animal
what was this my friend my friend Daniel
sloth Scottish comedian love Daniel he's
he's [__] fantastic he's got a bit
about all of the different weird animals
that he's he's seen an emotional support
peacock and he saw he's got this bit
about an emotional support hamster that
this woman uses like a [__] stress
ball and then when she kills it she
throws it away and takes another one out
of her pocket and starts going so
whenever I think about emotional support
animals I do this um yeah so you can do
eoin therapy with trained horses and
it's very simple like literally I mean
you can even if you have if there's a
ran near you you can ask to volunteer
and go just stand in a stable in a
paddock with a horse I now I know it
sounds crazy see if the horse wants to
be near you see if the horse wants to
gravitate towards your energy if you're
being in the present moment and you're
not unctuous in any way you're not needy
in any way you're not trying to get the
horse's attention you're not trying to
get the horse's love if you're just
taking care of yourself they will move
naturally towards you they don't need
anything from you because they're prey
animals they're grazers they can get
grass at any time where dogs want to be
near you because they're waiting for
food that dogs aren't loyal like they're
I love them but they have a vested
interest in being near you right I'm
like my dog loves me and then a stranger
opens car door and my dog jumps inside
I'm like wait horses have no need and no
allegiance to you right so this it's an
amazing exercise that had really help me
work on my energy because I'd be like
standing next to this horse standing
next to me they're grazing everything's
good then I'd be like okay well are they
going to move soon because like I just
what if what if they notice something
different or what if they and then the
horse starts moving away and then I
start going oh moved away I'm such a
piece of [__] they move even further
they just want to be as far from you as
possible and then when I start going
okay well this isn't going to work I
guess I should just okay what should I
do I guess I need to go home I need to
work out and then all of a sudden the
horse is coming back to you do do you
need someone or do you get someone when
you do eoin therapy to help you
integrate because it's not like the
horse is going hey hey chill out we need
to work on your chill out a little bit
like you need to think less about
[__] the house just a great way to
see the energy you're giving off it's
like a thermometer that's exactly it and
I didn't realize that I was giving off a
desperate needy energy and that I mean
people listening are like yeah we we
could tell you know I'm a comedian for a
Liv didn't need a horse Weather Vein for
that I'm like um you know I'm go on
stage for a living and I'm like love me
love me like me like me and then you
know I would move which is a very
important skill is being an Entertainer
is making sure that people on stage like
you but as soon as you get off stage
like you can't be bringing that energy
at people so it's about being
self-contained and it's about going like
I'm just going to be in the truth of
this present moment with this person
instead of trying to control whether
they like me or not because when you're
trying to make someone like you it's
very repellent yeah and it's interesting
that the horses were able to pick up on
it that being said the mental [__]
gymnastics that horse girls will go
through to just be able to spend more
time on a ranch it's like my horse is on
the back of a horse yeah no my [__]
my [__] horse is doing therapy with
me so I actually need to go I actually
need to go and see my therapist at I
would find I would go to a therapist and
just lie to them because I would try to
make the therapist like me or try to
impress them or try to be their most
[__] up or try to be their most
recovered or whatever it was Jimmy Carr
told me this thing while I was with him
saying the true definition of an
Entertainer is is if you don't like me I
don't like me Outsourcing your selfworth
to the crowd is comedians desperately
want to be loved but entirely on their
own
terms too real Jimmy it's too real yeah
it's way too real you know so I think
it's like you know what you do for a
living we're all you know we're reading
the comments we want to make sure the
people listening to us like us we want
to be perfect we want to get it right
but then you go on a date and you're
like trying to Ace the test and you're
just trying to ascertain if we like have
good chemistry and we can be you know
Alone Together kind of thing so I found
that like I had a really hard time
ascertaining the kind of energy I was
giving off this person from the other
side is just seeing someone performing
you're just performing for me here and
then you perform and then and then you
get them yeah and then they're in love
with someone that isn't you they're in
love with the person that's on stage or
the the equivalent of the stage now then
they go I love you and you're like you
don't know me yeah met you're in love
with that version of me yeah you you've
never met me yet and then or one day The
Jig Is up and you're exhausted and then
you're yourself and like You' never
you've never met me yet this such a an
awesome line that's really really cool I
did uh I do this breath work class in
Austin on a on a Thursday and um I went
last night and if you've ever it's not
super intense breath work but it's
enough like regulate the nervous system
and one of the things if you've never
done it for extended like half hour plus
period of time it's a little bit like
psychedelics it's a bit more difficult
to hold on to control or you just see
patterns arise a little bit more easily
uh and my executive function you know
that's what you kind of noticed as you
came in it's like me in around saying
Hey man can we just do this and blah
blah blah like that's always on and
um I wonder I think this is probably
quite a
common pattern for the sorts of people
that are listening that you can afford
to listen to us waffle on you know
talking about human psychology or
whatever um that there's a degree of
like wanting to do it right am I doing
it right like is this could I do it
better how can I optimize this am I I I
wonder if I breathe a little bit more
quickly would if I bre breath a little
bit more I hope that the the lady that's
teaching the class thinks that I'm doing
it right like if she comes near with the
thing like that energy of just it's like
an insecurity in some ways and one of
the weird externalities that comes from
this is it can be very very successful
right it drives you to be so detail
oriented to focus on things to uh a
degree of minua that gives you an
unbelievable competitive Advantage but
the felt sense of that can be you
tripping over these tiny tiny little
things and permanently being vigilant
right like the prey animal thing you're
being vigilant for what's the next thing
that needs to be fixed and the uh Mandy
the lady that takes the class yesterday
uh pipes up every so often it's [__]
great it's like sound healing with
breath work and then the final 30
minutes she just lets you do whatever
you wants I pay I pay someone to watch
me nap on a Thursday for a good amount
of time yeah um but she said uh at the
very beginning of the class of partway
through she said uh don't forget you're
not fixing a problem and I was like [__]
that's good like you're not trying to
fix a problem you're just doing the
thing I also think that these are
survival mechanisms that served us
really well and it helps I'm in a
12-step program called adult children of
Alcoholics it's basically if you grew up
in an alcoholic home in order for
alcoholism to be present alcohol doesn't
have to be present so if you didn't see
drinking it's fine if you grew up around
any kind of chaos as a child you became
a parentified child so if in any way you
had to parent your parents or take care
of self too young um you know we're the
kids that were so mature for our age and
we were the old soul and we're the ones
that made our own lunch and you know it
basically went I'm on my own here these
adults are you know do not have their
[__] together it looks like mature but
what it actually is is just survival
that's correct so I grew up in alcoholic
home divorce things are being a lot of
fighting I had to be hypervigilant it
served me really well as a child my mom
was going through a bad divorce she you
know drank a lot she was you know didn't
have the tools we all have that
generation didn't have podcasts like
this you know they didn't have um you
know these head space they didn't have
sound bath classes and stuff they were
just drinking and white knuckling
through it and so anytime I had a need
or a want she was very overwhelmed she
was crying at a very early age it was
like don't have any needs constantly
make sure that you know you're
self-contained self- deprived make sure
this is okay because if she comes home
and sees that this is messed up she's
going to have a contion and then I'm
going to have to deal with that so it
really helps there's a step in the
program that really helps you kind of
like you sort of anthropomorphize these
voices and be able to do this little
exercise where if you know I'm in the
sound bath class and it's like are you
doing it right and what if the
instructor doesn't think you're doing it
well enough and they don't think they're
good and I'm going I know what that is
don't need you right now going to need
you to sit back on the bench thank you
so much you helped me out when I was
six bye [__] you know so you're kind of
able to sort of like like personify it
in a way some people call it their
Shadow their inner bully whatever the
[__] you want to call it but there's
sometimes that I come off stage and it's
like that wasn't good enough and and
like thank you I want to be better at
this vocation that is actually when I do
need you so yeah get in the [__] game
CU I'm shooting a special in a week and
let's like crush this you know but I
don't need it when I'm in meditation
class so I like have those
little exercises I do that help what are
the modalities that have helped you go
from where you were in your 20s to
someone that feels like they've got
their [__] sorted now or be at least a
little bit close to being sorted God a
12 step program really helped me I just
feel like people you know talk about it
when it's like AA or na when it's like
you know recovering from what's na na is
Narcotics Anonymous like I think people
really talk about these 12-step programs
when it's recovering from a substance
but when you're in ACA or alanon it's
more about recovering from the internal
drug cabinet which is cortisol and
adrenaline so the drama addicts right
the sort of you know if you grew up in
alcoholic home you know you might
gravitate towards being in relationships
with people that you have to fix or
rescue or you're in these toxic
addictive relationships that you know
aren't really good but you can't really
get out and you're finding yourself
being the person that's like I hate
drama but you're always in some kind of
drama you know so for me I really had to
get a handle on that because I was in
relationships with people that I had to
rescue I was dating people I had to fix
I thought I had to take care of
everybody I was taking care of friends
like I was just always the crisis person
you know you feel alive in a time of
Crisis that's just our comfort zone
that's really served me in some of my
work situations but not in my personal
life it's a giant waste of time wasn't
taking care of myself um you know the 3M
we call it mothering micromanaging
martyring you know where putting
everybody else first putting yourself
last that just came naturally to me
doing that program really helped me to
not have guilt saying no to people being
able to stand up for myself not doing
anything out of obligation because I was
wasting so much time were you finding
yourself people pleasing a lot yep and
people pleasing we say is a form of
assholery because you're doing something
out of obligation you know like would if
I said to you like hey will you come do
my podcast and you were like oh God I
have to do what don't do me the favor
because that's so embarrassing to me do
you know what I mean it's like
patronizing it's like you know so it's a
lot of it's a lot of people pleasing you
know they call us the exploding doormats
you know super nice all the time to
everyone and then one day you just
[__] snap and you know you're
actually secretly keeping score you know
it's like and you're doing it to make
other people like you D so I had to like
un you know rewire a lot of that [__] I
got a lot of it from my mom um and like
deprogram what I believed was expected
of me Neil Strauss guy that wrote the
game now like [__]
reawakened you know totally aligned sort
of meditation person it seems uh I saw a
tweet from him a couple of weeks ago
that said unspoken expectations are
premeditated
resentments Jesus Christ yep he said c
dependence breeds resentments right
exactly it so it's like being in
relationships and going like like little
adages I do well with platitudes like
they just do complicated brains I think
do really well with little things you
know maxims maxims and aphorisms are a
huge way to synthesize down a bigger
message into something that you can
remember right like here is this very
large idea about how the story We Tell
ourselves largely determines our
experience of it because if your heart
rate's high after you've done a workout
you feel great but if your heart rate
just randomly was high in traffic you
would go to the hospital and then
there's this bit from Marcus aelius that
says uh the whole universe is change and
life itself is but what we deem it life
itself is but what we deem it I think
it's like nine words the most profound
nine words in philosophy yeah life
itself is but what we do encapsulates
all of this big thing y so like I
understand that quot porn and buking
people with all of these different these
different references is I don't know
maybe maybe it does get tiresome but for
me these these are the way markers that
remind me it's like a little Mantra it's
like right okay there's my
[__] desire for unproven self-esteem
again and I remember Ryan holiday saying
self-belief is overrated generate
evidence fantastic there we go I'll just
I know what to do yeah exactly and it's
I know if you're lost and the world's
kind of confusing at the moment and
people really don't know where to find
their meaning from and should I do the
career do the mother thing should I rely
on a partner can I trust relying on a
partner is he or she going to be [__]
baking in porn or [__] Kardashians or
whatever it might be it's like all right
we'll find somewhere firm and firm
things can be little philosophies and
principles that you rely on so yeah I'm
I'm did you say baking in porn maybe
sure what's baking mean I don't know
like just like [__] immersing
themselves like oh got it got it got
marinading in [__] porn got it got it
got it got it got it I thought you meant
she was in porn that would also happen
actually um okay so you said this ala
thing one them AC a total Miracle cuz
it's also free medicine um it's totally
free working with animals uh started
rescuing dogs fostering dogs I know this
is going to sound like crazy animal lady
but it really helped me because I
realized I had such self-esteem stuff
self-esteem stuff and I didn't have a
dog like I didn't have something that
was just giving me unconditional love
you know and it kind of that really
helped me I had some intimacy stuff and
I realized a lot of my toughness had to
do with being scared of intimacy being
scared of being loved maybe being scared
of being rejected or if you actually see
me you're going to reject me kind of
thing so animals really help me with
that because it gives you like you you
know just said the right a little bit of
data like this dog kind of you know I
kind of had to start there no matter how
much of a piece of [__] I might think I
am and how much I fear that the world
thinks I am my dog still loves I'm doing
pretty good yeah this thing that I think
is cool think he's alive he seems to be
happy that I'm here you had this uh I
heard you say this quote I think it's to
Chris um having a kid or maybe it was
him having a kid is the opportunity to
finally love something that isn't just
yourself I can't wait the clarity that
comes with just even being pregnant
right now has been so and the emotional
maturity that has come with it I highly
recommend being pregnant ladies it
really well because you kind of just
pregnancy is a therapy device that's a
[__] hot take I really is well
because it's like I mean I spend so much
time like going like should I do this do
I need to do this and I think that I've
always had this ticking clock on my
brain as a performer as like I'm a woman
I'm getting older am I going to expire
or am I just going to get tired like I
know I didn't want to you know work like
an animal forever I knew that like in my
20s and 30s I was like I I'm going to
grind like an animal and then I'm going
to have a personal life I always saw it
that way and maybe that's a little bit
like psycho I mean in my 20s like I was
in a couple relationships that were kind
of like two people kind of both trying
to avoid intimacy sort of thing but I
wasn't wasting a lot of time dating I
just I I didn't know what to do with
myself in terms of dating I know that I
wasn't ready to be serious with anybody
and I was like let me just check all
these career boxes and then I'll be able
to do the personal life thing I couldn't
manage doing both at ones I always
remember dude I I had this thought when
I was 16 and uh I was doing martial arts
I was doing like Kung Fu or something
and there was this Retreat that we went
to and one of the guys that was there
was in the Army and M had beaten it into
me from very early age I was going to go
to university first person I think first
person in my family to go to university
like [__] big extended family but one
of the only few people to go and uh
she'd always said you're going to
University you're going to University
but there was this point when we went to
this Retreat for Kung Fu and this guy
was there who was in the Army and he was
maybe a few years older than me and he
was just explaining about what life was
like and even then I was 16 before
social media before telephones before
anything right before telephones before
mobile phones and
um so a significantly less complex world
than the one that we find ourselves in
now and the one that many people that
are listening might only know right and
I remember looking at this guy who was
explaining about his experience in the
Army and thinking wow I would love to do
that purely because all of my efforts
would be committed to one thing and I
would never need to make decisions about
life and that kind of makes me think
about the same energy that's coming from
the opportunity to finally love
something that isn't yourself it's like
all I do keep this thing alive make you
happy yep yep and you know and it's it
and really quick just in terms of the
animal thing I also think that we waste
a lot of time you know trying to you
know as we say in program like you know
don't try to meet internal needs with
external things you know whether it's
drugs whether it's alcohol whether it's
people and for me I was never a drugs
and alcohol person but I was definitely
a people person with if I just have this
many friends if this High status person
likes me maybe I'm worth something if
this guy is attracted to me maybe that
means that I'm not you know totally
nothing but like having a lot of
emotional needs met from animals really
did I think keep me out of a lot of
trouble and I think we're you know I've
heard on your show talking about like
you know people not dating as much
anymore I know that's in a lot of ways a
bad thing but when you're in your 20s
like how do you get your emotional needs
met so you're not wasting time and
hurting other people and hurting
yourself being in relationships you
shouldn't be in you know and I think I
kind of accidentally hacked that by
fostering dogs I had like all these
animals I was always fostering and I'm
like crazy dog lady but like at least I
didn't have a kid before I was ready at
least I didn't marry someone I had no
business marrying and I feel like that
could have happened right so you had
your emotional needs met by surrogate
children furry furry surrogate children
yes but now it's like you know I got to
say a lot of the things that I've been
working so hard to try to get this
Clarity of like am I in this friendship
because of obligation am I in this
friendship because I'm confusing love
and pity and then you get pregnant
you're just like yeah I I you're a once
a month friend you're not a once a week
friend you might be like a once a year
friend quite frankly or like do I need
to buy this person a thank you gift
because they had no I texted thank you
that's enough you know there's like just
sort of a cal Simplicity there's a
Simplicity that comes over you um there
is a relief of bondage of self like you
know what we do for a living there's
just kind of this narcissism you can't
escape of like I wake up every morning
I'm like how can I improve myself today
how can I create something today what do
I need to do to stay relevant you know
just you're like you know what for today
I'm just going to eat well I'm going to
take care of myself and then like really
commit to all these routines that I've
kind of pretended to commit to for so
long you know in terms of taking care of
myself for me I you know there's a lot
of work about like the inner child and
like nurturing your inner now that I
have a literal inner child it's kind of
it really has all started to come
together so when I see people who have a
kid and their lives just get amazing I'm
like oh I get that because you really
start walking the walk that's so
interesting it's very Illuminating to
think about I don't know like the
forcing function of the kid bringing all
of your [__] to bear it's like look
you can't you can't be bothering again I
heard Chris talk about this when you
guys spoke uh where he said
um when he when his kids were young his
boys would be messaging back and forth
in the group chat did you see that such
and such a person did this and he
doesn't even he's like I'm not even
[__] got time to read this so all of
the extraneous [__] gets filtered
but I wonder whether and I certainly see
this with uh work um I saw this with uni
as well that the adrenaline of having
something very important and uh time
demanding and and on a a deadline and
dependent on you whether that be a
career or an education or you know a
political ideology that you're fighting
for on the Internet or whatever it is
it's exhilarating yep right it it it is
almost like a surrogate child in a way
and you're applying an awful lot of
pressure and a lot of attention toward
this thing and there is a sense of like
yes like I'm bringing something to bear
like this is manifesting in the world
but it's I no it's like a simulacrum of
what what you're actually working toward
right and it's also it's like no one if
you in my in when I was in my 20s told
me like hey money and fame is not going
to do it for you I'd be like [__] you
yes it will you know like it ever like
it's really just about family and you
can't take the money with you and you're
like okay I'm poor so I don't like none
of that [__] M no one wants to hear that
[__] so that's not what I'm about to say
in any capacity but to me I kind of go
like yes I've accomplished all of these
goals that I had I've had success I'm
financially solvent and you're like and
now what yeah and now what okay now am I
just I think you've talked about this
you have like one person you're doing
your career at yeah you know what I mean
like I'm doing I just did a six special
I'm like this was this just for this
other female comedian to know that I did
another one what is it like pick your
enemies about this the the question of
and now what and now what is so [__]
interesting like just keep running that
keep running that back right okay what
are you doing okay well I'm doing the
career thing okay and and then oh I'm
when I do this career I'll get the
promotion okay and then and then I'll
will be able to afford the house and
then and you just keep on running it all
the way forward and you go oh yeah
there's nothing there's no there there
eventually did it like did it did it
work did it make your dead Dad love you
like did it cuz I go like what's the
thing I'm going for like okay both my
parents are dead tried to get their
attention that didn't work okay it
didn't Unbreak My Heart from when I was
you know 31 and that thing happened it
didn't make me not getting asked to prom
go you know it's like you're kind of
like didn't do oh right I now what and I
feel like I was working towards all this
to be able to go I need to check all
these boxes so when I have a family I'm
not resentful
and I'm not still running around trying
to get these boxes checked because I did
watch a mother try to have a career and
I was slowing her down I felt it I
absolutely felt it how much of that you
know it's a really lovely narrative that
you've got woven together here which is
I did the hard things in my 20s and part
of my 30s that enabled me to be a mother
now can you remember how much of that
was planned in advance and how much of
that is you post Hawk rationalizing it
now and being like well this is a cute
story that put a bow on the top of this
B that's that's very interesting I mean
I think that I you know I think that at
the time I presented is one of these
women that goes well I don't want kids I
always said it I don't want kids which
is thou doth protest too much obviously
right we all become what we hate
whatever but I definitely present it as
no I'm not having kids I'm focusing on
my career H like I'm never I mean I had
a TV show that was about how I was
afraid of commitment and didn't want to
get married you know this was I was just
broadcasting my damage to everybody in
some way maybe to asked to be healed or
you know whatever it was or I was you
know very much like kind of grew up in
public so I did get a lot of feedback
which was interesting like it's
interesting to grow up in front of
people and show all your wounds and then
have people kind of confront you about
them it was weird like I wanted to get
better I wanted to change I wanted to
grow but I I definitely knew I didn't
want to have a family in my 20s I was
like CU I don't want to do what my
parents did and I'm too afraid of what's
in my I'm too broken you know was my
narrative and then by the time my 30s
came around I was was like I got engaged
wasn't quite right um I was really
trying but I just wasn't I wasn't healed
yet I just wasn't healed yet and I think
that I always had maybe it was my
codependence was saving me because I
didn't want to hurt anybody like I
really don't want to hurt anyone I
really when I'm in relationships and I
know it's not yeah that's interesting
that you were almost people pleasing the
imaginary partner that you hadn't yet
met I don't want to hurt them I know
that if I try and do this thing and it's
not going to go well then they'll be sad
and if they're sad I'm going to feel
like an absolute [__] piece of [__]
and I can't f it I just I can't I can't
lie I mean I think it's being a terrible
[__] lion being a comedian like I see
these people that are like if you have
80% of what you want you should settle
for that and I'm like but then how do
you I I'm not going to lie to this
person because then I won't respect them
because if they believe the lie then I
lose respect for them I'm like you just
bought that like I just I guess I might
be too much of a romantic which is not
how people would see me but I kind of
like really wanted this thing where two
people could be totally authentic
together and I wasn't capable of being
authentic until Fair recently there was
a a guy super successful guy who
completely stopped doing all online
content to switch to a different sort of
a business and I was at a retreat with
him few months ago maybe four months ago
something like that and I was talking to
him and I was saying you know he he
stopped doing the online content thing
because he had a bigger project and a
bigger business that he loved and he
felt like he was contributing to the
world in a better way through but
another thing that he said to me which
is really [__] stuck with me was he
found himself saying things not only as
content but also to his friends and this
is one of the reasons why he stopped
being quite so social he found himself
telling people stories in public that he
then felt like he needed to live up to
in
private so he was weaving and that was
the reason I asked about the beautiful
bow that's upon the box it's like this
is a nice story right but how much of it
is just a good thing that not only you
can tell yourself but also sounds great
on a podcast and how much of that is
really there and it's really hard you
know it's not the sort of thing that
you're going to unpack like that um but
that that one [__] sentence I sat in
a Jacuzzi with like [__] 16 guys the
gayest thing ever but
um and he says this thing and here's me
having like a mini [__] existential
crisis is the heavens open I'm like wow
that's super profound I must remember to
write that down and uh yeah I was
telling myself stories in in telling
stories in public that I had to live up
to in private okay then I'll tell you
the ugly Parts um that that don't have
the bone necessarily is I do think that
you know um and and I sometimes I I get
a little bit um wishy-washy about saying
things that I feel like only apply to
forward- facing people you know I'm like
oh is this not applicable but everybody
now has social media everybody now is
public in some you know kind of way and
there's a sort of micr version of what
we do for everybody and I think that
starting a podcast I you know look I had
done a special a year was kind of you
know what you do as a comedian you tore
around the country that you start a
podcast and you're kind of broadcasting
all of your personal details of your
life you're talking about dating people
you're talking about sexual stuff and I
think it hurt me I definitely think I I
um had to start really looking at that
and just going like would the guy that I
want to be would sign up for this and me
being completely open about all of my
sexual conquests in the past and so on
and so forth which I which is half the
time you're we're joking we whatever it
is but I just kind of was like I don't
know if the guy that I want to be would
want to be with a public figure let me
give you this so one of my smartest
friends Mary Harrington one person you
need to get on your podcast is Louise
Perry so she wrote the case against the
sexual Revolution yes Mary is like uh
she's just another version of Louise
basically from from the UK very smart
lady and she came up with this idea of
digital modesty and digital modesty uh
she says that there needs to be
boundaries about what people share on
the internet and she's got different
ones she's like a little bit more kind
of uh reclus and she's a writer rather
than a podcaster so I guess that makes a
little bit of a difference as well but
um you know she talks about I'll never
post photos of my kids where I live the
places that I go to like like she's got
this big list and it's a set of
principles that she doesn't cross I
don't think a partner exists on the
internet Bret Cooper just got engaged
from the daily wire I think the first
and last time anyone on the internet's
going to see her fiance future husband
was like the back of his head in a a a
photo of them getting engaged in Rome or
wherever it was and she came on and she
said I got engaged and it was this thing
she spent maybe 4 minutes talking about
it and then said and that's the last
time that I'm going to talk about my
partner and it was like he's not on the
internet he doesn't want to be on the
internet and I love him for it and it's
like that um digital modesty and but
you're totally right as well you can be
a person who is living the most normal
non public facing life in the world but
you've got you know 2,000 followers on
Instagram and your friends from school
are still keeping up to date with what
you do via Facebook like you have these
rules too and in some ways those people
are even more intimate in your lives
because they've been a part of it for so
long and they know your cousins and they
know where Mom and Dad live and blah
blah blah and it was hard to develop
intimacy with people when I have such an
intimate relationship with the people
that have read my book and listen to my
podcast and then you sit down with
someone that you've been with for six
months and they're like oh I didn't know
you struggle with eating stuff and I'm
like well I wrote a book up what and
you're like oh wait second like you
haven't heard everything that I've said
you know like and then it's this weird
thing where you're like you're like am I
attracting people that want to be with
someone that's like this and then I have
to live up to the person you also have a
degree of uh like narcissism guilt about
the presumption that people would have
seen the thing that you it's like what
you didn't read my [__] book but I
didn't but which by the way thank God
you didn't you wouldn't be here if you
had but also it's more like oh I don't
want to make the Assumption obviously
that you didn't but I also like we can
talk about other things too and I've
already talked about this too much I
don't even but then they feel like
they're left out of things they'll be at
the airport and someone will be like I
loved your book I you moved me so much
when you talked about this right and
then yeah and then they're like wait a
second when you were engaged and I'm
like well yeah I mean it just hasn't
come up page page 235 and then yeah
totally and guys are like why do these
strangers know more about you than I do
and I'm like well because I don't I mean
this is why I think for for a lot of
people regardless of how big or small
the platform is as soon as you start to
broadcast things about yourself on the
internet even to your you know thousand
yeah thousand friends on Instagram you
then create another you out there there
is you that is this and then there is
the you that is the online Persona and
people will make judgments about that uh
Telly who I think is patient [__]
zero for what we're talking about uh
[__] what's her name Alex Cooper from
call her daddy yeah like yeah this is a
girl who built her platform talking
about like the GL GL 7,000 how to give a
good [__] on episode whatever of a
podcast and just rolls forward extoling
the virtues of casual sex and no strings
attached attachment and treat them like
you don't like him and this is what I
got up to last night and marriage is a
con and you don't need to get into a
relationship and familyhood and you can
do the girl boss thing and sisters all
Sisterhood forever and then for the last
three years it's been dating this guy
and then like [__] like a a
transition just [__] re gender
reveals herself to be like a [__]
matronly and girls there was rose pedals
and the The Proposal was so beautiful
and stuff and I'm like do you know the
wake of the cultural like Aftershock
that's occurred behind you Downstream of
all of these girls believing this
ideology that you for a good amount of
time for like two or three years weren't
living like you know and that must have
caused I'm sure that in her like she'll
be able to feel that Discord it's too
easy for me to say you know uh she was
saying one thing and doing another and
[__] her for that because you know I'm
I'm sure that she's struggled internally
with that unless she's complete
narcissist and I don't think she is but
there is a bit that goes like dude come
on like think about all of the [__]
girls that have cast off relationships
and done the casual sex thing to allow
guys to use and discard them thinking
that that was true feminine Liberation
meanwhile you were getting ready to get
engaged right right right that is wild I
I didn't it's interesting because you
know as someone that in my standup I
talked a lot about that stuff in my 20s
but I'm actually really shy about that
stuff other like sex otherwise like I'm
weirdly shy about it so you know I I
haven't heard all of it but yeah I mean
you know look Snoop Dog said you can't
make a hoe housewife maybe you can I
don't know I don't know but I definitely
do feel like one of the you know biggest
problems people do now we were kind of
talking about it right as we came in is
they over pathologized themselves and
kind of trauma Bond on the first date
all of a sudden people are talking about
their depression and their anxiety and
this is what happened to me when I was a
kid and my ex cheated on me it's like
why the [__] are you doing this on a
first date like this is not first I mean
that's something you share way way later
and I think people are getting
relationships way too soon because
they're trauma bonding too soon but I do
feel like because I tend to kind of
overshare for a living on podcast that's
what we do you know to try to help other
people and then I'm like oh God I hope
any guy that I could ever date would
never listen to any of this well there's
something else about that digital
modesty side which is if you're already
showing all of you on the internet where
is left to go that has additional
intimacy beyond that but then you just
go like am I changing everything about
my career for this one person and the
answer is kind of yes you're going like
I'm not going to post this video in case
this one person I'm interested in might
see it which is a wild sacrifice to make
you know this might not even work out
but like if he Scrolls past this and
sees me being like GL GL or whatever I
don't know whatever Alex is doing like
I'm GNA lose the guy this is this would
make the kind of guy that I want
probably recoil and flee and go like no
thanks yeah it's well I mean you know we
were talking you mentioned before about
people pleasing and what you're
basically doing there is saying the
words that you think the person wants to
hear without thinking the things that
justify the thing that you're saying
it's like I'll say yes to going to the
party despite not wanting to go to the
party because I want to please the
person even though if they could see the
inner texture of my own thoughts they
would be like they would just feel so
patronized and disgusted at the fact
that I don't think they're able to take
the news and then also by the way like
what do you think they're going to
cancel the party the the insecure
narcissism that I'm a piece of [__] in
the center of the universe of that of
like well if I don't go they're going to
what cancel it they'll be fine we obsess
about what other people think about us
till we realize they're not thinking
about us I think that's the same with uh
people trying to go through breakups in
relationships and they're like how would
they ever be able to live without this
you know I mean they're entire yeah it's
like be fine they may even be better
yeah the hinge lady wrote a book they'll
be fine but I do think there is a point
where it's like I see people going like
well I'm ready to be serious in a
relationship I'm like does your social
media reflect that you're ready to be
serious relationship do your dating apps
reflect that you're ready to be in a
serious relationship it's like the idea
of like before you're ready to get in
something you got to make sure you have
made space for it like a lot of people
are like dating a bunch of people
casually or they're kind of in something
and they're like I want something real
it's like you got to really be ready and
I had to get to a point where I to go
like I have to go delete all these
photos from my I have to delete all
these videos did you go in to cleanse
you sanitized your Instagram I had to I
mean look I had blue hair for like a
year I had that did you did you have a
did you go [__] crazy what did you do
I guess I kind of did I okay so during
the pandemic you know stand up was the
first thing to go I mean in California I
don't know when you came were you in
California first no or you just went
came UK and then back into 2021 I came
here nice you came straight here great
so in California it was like shut down
right and so standup was the first thing
to go and I had just spent so much of my
career career as like you know someone
in television and stuff is having to
sort of be this person and you know
you're trying to make this like
executive have a crush on you to get
this job I just was like sick of trying
to be this perfectly castable person and
then on top of that you know knowing
that I had a year off and then a bunch
of my friends started losing their jobs
um hair artists makeup artists stuff
like that and then I had one who you
know was going to have to move back home
lose her health insurance and I was like
what's the most expensive thing we can
do and she's like let's diee her hair
blue and I'm like [__] it I'm an
Entertainer why not you know I'm not
shooting anything right now I didn't
realize that when you have blue hair
everyone thinks you're like a lesbian on
ketamine so it's like I think that
probably set me back in the dating in
the dating pool for a while CH what why
why can't you have blue hair guys just
they're just like she's nuts I have I
think that blue hair especially like
that color of hair is just it it's got
broad B brond imaged you know what I
mean but you know what's weird about it
a lot of guys started showing up at my
house that thought I was some anime
there's like you were cosplaying is
there's some there it's a really big
fetish in some twitch communities and
and people that think we're in a s l cut
top and started playing League of
Legends that would have been that was
your new career there was there's some
video game character that is so funny
that's truly it's never happened to me
in a podcast not one time is that your
ringtone that's what yes it's the most
like California new
Agy some [__] binaural beats at a
ringtone that's like the first ringtone
that's like the one that comes with the
phone I thought that's crazy I just got
the new phone and I I don't know how to
use it but um yeah I did make the
mistake but again if I wasn't a public
figure I was didn't put it on social
media like you know people are she's got
blue hair and I'm like how many like
great guys were like never mind you know
so I think it was just about going like
I've spent most of my career trying to
appease fans and being Entertainer and I
have to just go like I'm going to have
to take a hit in my career if I really
want to have a personal life well I
think you know for a lot of people again
that aren't necessarily in medor or
whatever there is a a degree of feeling
like you need to live up to whatever
expectation it is the Norms of this time
this generation your parents your past
traumas the paths of least resistance
confused chemical signals of your body
like whatever it is that you're kind of
being dragged by at the moment and
asking yourself the question all right
so what's me where am I inside of this
deeper if I dig a little bit deeper do I
hit anything solid or am I just this
concatenation of a bunch of assumptions
and and projections of my idea of what
other people actually want from me it's
like you just made me realize something
which is like I was arrogant and there
was this well I'm just going to be
authentic and I have blue hair and I do
this and I talk about sex still
performance and you take me or leave me
and if you don't like me you don't
[__] get it and it's like no the
person that would would have been
attracted to that like is not the kind
of person I want to be with either you
know so I don't want to gravitate bat
gravitate batshit crazy people either so
like I can't behave batshit crazy all
the time you know and expect to vibrate
a person at the frequency of what I want
so it's like a lot of people go like
like this is what I want in a man and
this is what I want in a woman and it's
like well what are you willing to give
up and I wasn't ready to make that list
I had my list of Pros my list of cons my
list of red flags my list of green
lights but I didn't have what are you
willing to give up are you willing to
give up those
photos that are like silly and your ass
is out are you willing to give up those
videos where you're going like man
making fun of men are you willing to not
put up that standup clip from when you
were 22 about squirting like so what's
interesting there is uh for each culture
there's a counterculture right so I
think that's not far off like uh
sacrifice culture or something like that
it's realizing that your partner is
there are things that you can do that
can make your partner more and less
happy but there would be a big uh part
of the internet perhaps the like uh
female empowerment authenticity boss
pitch internet that would say well if
your partner can't take you as you are
that's their insecurity and their
problem and you go okay well do you
agree that there are ways that you can
make your partner feel better and worse
do you think that that's a thing yes
there are on average do you want to try
and do things that make your partner
feel better without compromising
yourself and becoming totally pliable
yeah probably that would be something
it's like right okay so we are on the
same page it's just a difference of
degree not a difference of kind so how
many things like are you going to go out
every single night partying with the
girls and never see your partner
probably not right that's not going to
be a good relationship and they're going
to feel uncomfortable with it all right
so as soon as we accept that it's one
straight line to there were things that
I will put on the internet the digital
modesty thing again there are things
that I will say about myself there are
ways that I will act there are things
I'll say behind their back you know to
my friends that I will and will not say
you know there's degrees of um
confidentiality and and openness about
what we get up to in the bedroom or
about you know what his fears are about
what she's been doing like all of these
things uh like I don't know it seems
kind of noble to me to do that I 100%
agree and it's also there's a difference
between you know I've spent a lot of
time with magical thinking and that's
what magical think is I'm going to go
out my girlfriend's three nights a week
and if he doesn't accept it he's a well
then you're going to get a certain kind
of man I'm at a point again I've nothing
to prove like I think for what I say to
women is like get to a place where you
have nothing to prove so you can toally
submit to your man and it doesn't feel
like you're like a bad femin there's
this thing now where you can't like if
you cook for your man you're not a good
feminist I'm like you're dealing with
knives and fire it's cool like being
able to feed yourself and your family is
like a bad thing now like I you know I
just I think it's like so Noble to be
able to go like I can show my love for
you by giving up all these other things
and I just want to make you happy like
it's what I do on stage it's what I do
with crowds it's like I want to do it
with a man is that weak is that it's
investment right it's it's so strange
that uh a woman who would give herself
over and and a man that would give
themselves over to a corporate employer
that doesn't give a [__] about them is
somehow seen as being a virtuous like
self-defining independent person but
someone that does that for a partner
that's going to spend the rest of their
life with them and genuinely care is
seen as a s I had a I also think that um
a big mistake women make is like women
go to advice about men to their
girlfriends go to advice about men to
your guy friends and also don't go to
your single girlfriends for advice about
being in relationships go to your
married friends yeah well I mean all of
your single friends want tequila
Tuesdays to keep happening which means
that that you know even if they're not
aware of it and even if they're
fantastic friends there is a part of
them that thinks it's kind of like
there's this idea in uh the black pill
incel world of ascending and ascending
is um becoming a viable mate for women
and maybe maybe even getting into a
relationship and it's very heav
discouraged because if one of the guys
within a group that are supposed to be
genetic dead ends that have no hope does
do something that creates a pain of oh
well this could happen to me and as soon
as you be believe that this could happen
to me maybe the reason it's not
happening to you is your fault maybe
it's not determined already and it's
kind of the same with the Singleton
thing like if you're going to go and ask
for advice about intimacy with someone
who never really seems to be intimate
with anyone they're going to first off
not have a a particular fantastic
perspective I don't think unless they're
unbelievably incisive but secondly
there's going to be a little bit of a
perverse incentive that they don't want
their friend to start to pull away from
them uh oh so interesting I'm going to
give you the advice that makes what I'm
doing seem like a good idea and also
keeps you as a compatriot so that we can
both continue to do this together you
know we The Sisterhood like you know
girl you don't need him etc etc it's
like well maybe maybe that is yeah maybe
that's maybe that's true but like if you
are unable guy or girl is unable to get
yourself a partner or unable to find
friends like no dude you don't need that
friend anymore it's like the subtext of
that is you can hang out with me I'm
your people when I was um I don't know
gosh I was probably my late 20s and I
dated a and I I'm only saying what he
does for a living because it might make
people like um it'll make make you
understand why I took it so uh well
professional athlete great at what he
does I just think lot of times
professional athletes they don't they
can't there's not a lot of room for
emotion to be involved it's either true
or it's not true or you're going to get
your neck broken you know and he you
know dated a lot of you know could date
whoever he wanted or sleep with whoever
he wanted and I REM I was just in my
arrogance and in my like you know we
were like arguing about something and I
was like well like why would you date me
if like I'm the person you date if you
want like a
challenge and he just went why would any
man want a challenge in their
relationship and it was like I was like
thank you so much for saying that cuz I
guess I grew up watching parents fight
watching conflict is love conflict is
love I guess that's what I saw I guess I
thought it was sexy I guess I thought
men passion is yes I don't know what I
was thinking and I literally in that
moment was like oh my God I'm so like I
don't know what I I thought it was like
hot to you I thought it was like what
guys wanted I thought it was like feisty
like you know I apologize well
especially if you're dating somebody
that is high performing in any realm has
goals you know if you're working that
hard in the office you really want to
come home and be like right there's that
to-do list done I wonder what fires I
need to fight when I step through the
front door as well and now I'm kind of
at this point where it's like I'm good
at business I'm really good at what I do
I love the idea of being with the man
where I can be like how can I help you
make your like how can I be your
business partner like your silent
business partner whether it's like I can
have dinner waiting for you I can Dwayne
The Rock Johnson probably needs a second
one of those I mean look I is so crazy
to me yeah they probably I want do I
mean State of California woman though
she gets half for after 10 years in a
day strange if you even with a prenup oh
that's a good question I don't know
you'd be surprised how few people have
prenups I mean remember he's got that
[__] whatever it is what's his is it
rum emotional support oh uh his rum
brand it's like tequa or Rum or
something and uh I mean he's I heard he
might warn for office too I'd vote for
him you know cuz that's another thing is
like like I'm into that ride or die how
can I make your dreams come true like
that's I've made my dreams come true
like it's I'm into that Kink of like how
can I make your dreams come true like
can I being in service is is cool
especially if it's and this is something
that we spoke about before as well like
not doing it coming from a place of
desperation I want to make your dreams
come true or make your life better
because I think it'll make you love me
but there's almost something
extra sexy or seductive about somebody
putting their nature especially their
public facing nature to one side in
order to do something that seems
opposite or different to that privately
because it it seems like the love that
you have for me is causing it's so
strong that you're having to overcome
something that you do publicly you know
it's the same reason why the
high-powered male lawyer wants to be
tied up and and spanked by the
dominatrix right it's it's the PO
polarity of the life that makes it
interesting yes and that's the
difference between coming at it from a
place of desperation and weakness like I
want to do this because I think it's the
only way that you'll love me versus I am
fine on my own and I'm okay with being
independent and I have all of this stuff
going for me and I still want to you
know be the Homemaker build a family do
the whatever and it's the same for
that's why like the Chad to Dad pipeline
is so alluring I think to women it's why
so many stories all of the dark romance
novels are about a man who has
everything who is completely independent
and ruthless and and domineering and
prestigious and is softened over time by
the right woman because his love for her
pulls him in and it's the same as a
beautiful friendship story right there
is a friend who who struggles to connect
but you see something in them that's
amazing and then you become friends
together and you do you know the
Michelangelo effect do you know what
this
[__]
brilliant um it's a psychological effect
that describes how over time two people
often in a relationship will craft each
other into the idealized version of what
they want so I make you more like what I
want and you make me more like what you
want and I am happy to become more like
what you want and you are happy and the
reason it's called the Michelangelo
effect is you can imagine Michelangelo
looking at this huge block of marble and
from the outside it's Ru Hune but over
time he chips away and creates the
statue of David so he sees inside of
something which isn't perfect the
Perfection that he wants and over time
is able to craft this thing out of it
this is something that's making me think
of of something I think that actually
would be helpful to people and is I feel
like when you're in a relationship with
somebody and there's things that you
want to change about the there's this
new thing now where you just can
criticize your man or criticize your
person or someone comes home and it's
like I so you're just going to walk in
the door and not say hi and da d da and
this is where the you know my having
more intimacy and relationships with
animals and humans actually comes in
handy where positive reinforcement is
pretty much I believe the only thing
that works and I think that I'm not
seeing it on either side right now with
men or women so if like your girl comes
home and she's rough or she's going out
with her friends too whatever it is just
experiment with like just say instead of
getting in a fight about it like just
you know what I love like I love when
you come home I come home and you're
here and you're like on the couch and
you're Barefoot it's just the sexiest
thing in the world to me when I like
come home and you're here you know and
like kiss her on the forehead and just
see if anything Chang same thing with my
girlfriends you're like and I just told
him that he needs a and I'm like are you
insane you can't talk to people like
that you know this isn't like you're not
in a fight on the [__] Subway this is
your man just tell them like you know
what I love it so much when you like I
don't like that he wears this thing when
he wears the other thing just tell him
how hot it is and suck his dick what why
is this so hard to understand and I you
can't wear those [__] and Crocs around
when he wears the other shoes just suck
his dick and tell him how much you love
the shoes and kiss them and it's over
you know so I just think that we're not
doing enough positive reinforcement I
think maybe it's this like perfectionism
generation or maybe we're all standing
up for ourselves and I'm going to make a
boundary and I'm going to tell you all
the things that I don't like because I'm
going to be authentic and da d da
omissions are not lies you know I just
think that for every criticism we have
it's just like like just try positive
reinforcement try that you know what I
love I love when your phone is off and I
just get to like we just as opposed to
why do you always have your phone out on
the table it always makes me so annoyed
that's it don't even say that one just
when there's no phone out take that
opportunity to tell them how great it is
like this to me is about like that's
what it means to be soft I think to just
like bite your tongue shut your [__]
mouth you don't have to just be roasting
your man all the time I mean I see it
and there's certain rules to me that I
live by in relationships now it took me
a while to learn but you never gossip
about your man ever ever if there's a a
texting with some other girl you don't
I'm like you don't tell any of your
girlfriends you take it to a therapist
you take it to a 12-step meeting like
don't ever gossip about your person
don't ever make fun of your person in
public I see people a lot like that
women that don't understand why
relationships aren't working and then
you go out on a double dat and like cuz
he [__] can't get and you're just
like what the [__] are you doing yeah
like you're embarrassing your man in
front of a bunch of people you know and
so I see this stuff and if someone who's
a female comic you would think that you
know that's that's not how I am in
relationships in the slightest and I
think that we're just like getting a
little too comfortable you know I did
this movie that was about it was based
on a book called the female brain and I
met with this female neuroscientist and
I said to I was just like what's the
main advice you have for me like if I
leave here knowing one thing today about
the difference between the male and the
female brain and she just went your
girlfriend is not your
boyfriend what do you mean by that don't
treat them the same so if you want to
talk about how ugly the bridesmaid's
dresses were at Marcy's wedding call
your friend Lydia don't call your
boyfriend about it you know just like be
a little more cautious about the stuff
that you because then you come home and
you're like can you believe what
happened at work and this she was
wearing this blouse and the guy's just
like you know what I mean it's like well
you don't listen to me how come you're
not paying attention you don't want to
hear me talk it's like this isn't a
subject dud you're boring you're [__]
boring dude call your girlfriend so it's
like to me it's always a big red flag
when girls don't have girlfriends cuz
that means you're going to have to hear
all the boring ass [__] so like girls
know what to take to your girlfriends
and know what to take to your guy or to
your boyfriend you know I think that's a
really important thing that a lot of
girls don't do they expect their
boyfriend to be their girlfriend you're
not going to come to [__] Nordstrom
with me and hold my purse while I change
that's not the man that's not my guy you
know and don't make your guy do [__]
like that you know I just I just think
that like you know little things like
that I think make a really big
difference and if you are doing that
chances are you might not respect the
person and that's not the person for you
and I think people really forget about
respect it's like I'm attracted to him
and he's smart and he has this but do
you respect him cuz if you're going I
want you to spend your Saturday sitting
on a [__] velvet puff at Nordstrom
while I try [__] on unless it's like a
fun Kakey sex game that's a different
thing but like that's not respect you
don't respect your man's time yeah
that's again the pliability thing and
that's why having boundaries is so
important you said this other thing I
listen to you say this other thing I
thought was so [__] interesting you
said in order for art to imitate life
you have to have a life that's it and
this
is definitely something that I see in
high Achievers High performers people
that are sort of on that grind where the
creativity and the space that they had
to be able to think about whatever it is
that they're going to do whether it's
business or career moves or writing or
an online coaching platform that they're
trying to start or content creation or
whatever uh and after a while you take
up so much of your days doing that thing
that the font uh like the pool from
which you withdraw in order to be able
to present [__] is just Barren it's dry
that's that's exactly it I mean you see
it with comedians all the time you see
these great comedians amazing
observational comedians they get more
and more famous more and more successful
all they're doing is touring and then
all of a sudden they're only doing jokes
about airplanes because they're only on
airplanes you know or they like have
nothing to talk about because they don't
do anything I remember I was in a
writer's room for a sitcom that I made
and I was running three shows at one
time three television shows which was
very you know taxing was working all
weekend you know 20 hours a day not
sleeping and we're in the writer's room
and I'm like we need to pitch on like
something that the couple does like on a
weekend and someone was like oh what if
they like went to a wine tasting and I
was like no one goes to a wine tasting
and then like what if she like had to go
to a baby shower I'm like no one goes to
a baby and they're like no Whitney you
don't go to a b like you don't have a
you know and I realized like I was
limiting myself and how you know I'm
like well what if like they're at work
and this happened like I could only
pitch on workaholism like and every
character was all of a sudden a
workaholic I you know and so to me it's
like you know especially being you know
a standup comedian I'm like like I got
to go out in the world and I got to do
things and that doesn't mean be
mercenary when you do because there are
times where I'm like I really have to do
something social this week and I'll call
friends and I'll be like can you guys
make sure I don't turn this dinner into
work or turn a hobby into a business
because that's the other thing is that
I'll get a hobby and then I'll turn into
a business yeah you know I mean spin
this thing up and sell it I'll start
knitting and I'm like oh this will be
good merch and I'm like no can't do that
you know there's a an idea I came up
with for that called productivity
Purgatory so it's one of the things that
you do for fun and done purely to like
you go for walk in nature not because
you want to calm down and just have a
good time but because you once saw an
Andrew hubman podcast that says your
productivity increases by 15% if you
spend 20 minutes a day with sunlight in
the eyes or whatever like productivity
Purgatory everything that you do is in
service of this of this thing I
literally got the Apple watch because
the phone is just a camera at a certain
point and I would go on these hikes and
then I would be like I got to do a video
about there's a plant and I got to do a
bit with the I'm like NOP I got to just
not even bring my phone with me on walks
anymore CU I will find way to make a Tik
Tok or or I'll be writing down I'm like
I got to just like you know so I really
have to play defense on that because I
will slip into that workaholic [__] or I
mean just being on a date with a guy and
being like that's not a just stop nope
that's not a joke you're just in the
moment and you're not going to make
write a scene you're not going to get a
movie idea you're just going to be in
this moment you know and I think that
for people that do all kinds of things
it's not even just creators if you're
someone that's like building an app or
this you have to go out in the world and
see how people behave and see what they
do do and you got to like go to the zoo
is basic I call it going to the zoo you
got to go out to a restaurant and see
like okay I'm I'm building my my whoop
band okay people usually wear it on the
left side would you know you just have
to like be in the world and I I I didn't
I always thought that socializing doing
things that were fun were like a waste
of time or that I was falling behind you
know um but now I know that it's like an
integral part about being creative and
staying relevant and it's good to have
fun every now and then like you've
earned it I think that I used to operate
from such a place of like guilt and
you're such a piece of [__] and you're
never going to make it and that served
me really well it just doesn't serve me
anymore yeah this I've got this idea
about uh fuel that you use that kind of
a fuel that
very uh anxious sort of toes toes down
forward thing is potent for probably
about five or 10 years but toxic if you
use it for much longer than that I'm
also big my new thing is doing nothing
okay how do you how you getting on with
doing nothing it's weird I mean a lot of
times it's kind of just like sitting
outside and just I get to look at nature
chilling but there's just no such thing
as doing nothing I think being around
horses wouldn't class because that's
still doing something if I'm well that
still counts as doing something probably
a little bit but doing nothing next to a
horse they really like you uh Dr k a
healthy gamer he's a a psychiatrist
psychotherapist eastern and western
trained and he helps with young people
that have got um screen addictions
gaming addictions he also works with
some of the biggest twitch streamers on
the planet he's done with every big
twitch xqc and and Charlie from penguin
zero and all that stuff and um one of
his exercises that he gets his like
Discord group to do is stare at the wall
for 30 minutes and some of the things
that apparently people break down crying
they start screaming at the wall you're
like dude it's staring at a wall I
haven't done it I haven't [__] I dare
do it I don't know if I'm going to it
would be a total fever dream I don't
know what it's going to go on I It's
tricky because I I was almost too
embarrassed to say it uh but a lot of
times I end up crying if you're just
like being alone with yourself cuz
you're like what's what am I running
from What feelings am I trying to not
feel what thoughts am I trying to not
have or what comes up when I stop
anesthetizing with busyness with action
with productivity right and it might
just be
like you know that agent that did like
it's right there it's right there oh
that person that said that thing or that
YouTube comment like it's right there
and to go like okay this is stuff I need
work through this is stuff that I'm
caring this is stuff that I need to
purge this is someone I need to forgive
like this is something like a Mal I'm
that I'm um trying to get a feeling I'm
trying to get out of right that is
haunting me or it's something that's
taking up real estate in my brain that
has no business being there that if I
don't feel this feeling it's just going
to you know alchemize into something
unhealthy anger at someone else or some
kind of shame or [__] so it's like
it's like I kind of sit there and
sometimes have to feel my feelings and a
lot of times it's shame shame it's
cringe it's God why did you say that
thing to that person you know sometimes
it's to forgive myself whatever it is
but like you know there was um I don't
know if you ever saw that show cheer on
Netflix no it's about the best
cheerleading uh it's such a great
documentary about the best cheerleading
team uh in the country uh Nao it's
actually in Texas the coach is
incredible it's so great such an amazing
show it's about you know these cheeries
they work wasn't there a big Scandal
there was a scandal one of the guys send
some he shouldn't have sent and asked
for some photos he shouldn't asked for
but it's still incredibly inspiring it
will inspire you not to send those DMS
okay yeah um and to never never DM
somebody without having seen their
driver's license um and uh and why am I
bringing it up why am I bringing it up
oh so one of the girls on it they all
got really famous off of it the show was
really big and this girl's just like 18
years old famous cheerleader you know
she's getting all these brand deals she
all of a sudden has four million
followers from being on this Netflix
show being this you know athlete and
I'm in uh in Austin with some friends
and we go see they do this live show and
I you know the show came out like a year
and a half ago and I asked her I was
like so what didn't you do this summer
and she was like oh I'm going to take a
couple months off just to you know
process and I was
like what she's like I just need to like
process all this and I was like I don't
get like I it I didn't know what she was
I was like oh yeah I need to schedule
time to process things I've never
thought about that before and it made me
start to take time every week to just
process what happened so I uh I'm
incorporating in America it's taken ages
because your guys' tax system and legal
system and everything I only got social
security number two months ago anyway um
started working with accountancy firm so
I've kind of got a part-time CFO
part-time CFO [__] all he does is
finances and I was at dinner with him a
couple of nights ago and he said yeah
every Friday I just have the entire day
to think like yo you live on XL like
what thinking is there it's it's just
numbers in numbers out like am I doing
deals has this person paid their taxes
blah blah blah like what thinking is
there to do and the accountant guy the
head of this accountancy firm is like
yeah I spend every Friday just thinking
obviously that's a luxurious position to
be in but like the rule I think is right
I used to I used to have this uh um
again another problem you guys have a
license equivalency between the US and
the UK which means I need to take my
theory test my theory driving test again
in Texas a place that has by far the
worst drivers I've ever seen in my life
and I've been to Rome right so I I I
have to do that again but I used to love
when I was back home a really great hack
s sorry we don't give half of our money
to a queen yeah that's true well she's F
not anymore oh yeah it's a it's a tough
day um sorry our our our leaders aren't
born into Power yeah yeah if you had a
genetic pool about that big sorry we
don't have inbred mascots running our
country all right okay there we there we
go I'm sure you're going to need to sell
some tickets in the I'm kidding I'm
kidding yeah I know love you guys love
you
guys.com yeah um driving in the car with
no music or podcast on W what a [__]
like wow what a crazy thing you know
what I mean what comes up and it's great
because you've got the front of your
it's like doing nothing when you're
washing the dishes your front of the
brain is nice and nice and occupied and
the rest of the brain is just free to do
its thing really great really great I do
have a a tool that really works for me
where I schedule worrying about things
and schedule worrying about things I
schedule worrying about things so it's
like if it's like I have to make this
decision about whether I'm going to do
this thing or not say the deadline is
November 12th I'll go okay November 10th
and I'll put it in my calendar I'll say
10 a.m. to this I'll worry about it
instead of just constantly perseverating
it until about it until then I will just
schedule when I'm going to worry about
it do you do that with somebody do you
find it's easiest to worry in with a
right hand or with a like if I know I
need to run something by someone I'll go
like hey like come and worry with me
yeah can you come can we go panic
together or if I'm like because it gives
me time to also go who are the best
people to reach out and ask about this
like I feel like it's also your life
starts getting better when you know who
to ask advice from you know again go to
married people to ask Rel advice for you
know podcast go to someone who knows
what they're talking about you know so
for me it's also instead of just talking
about it to everyone all the time and
getting bad advice from people getting
sort of mixed data just constantly
worrying about something I'll go like
you have two hours to worry about this
in 3 weeks and then I also will schedule
making decisions about things I get
really bad decision fatigue so it's like
we were just talking about like making
decisions about you know sponsors and
stuff like that you know I can go like
okay I'm going to make this decision on
this date at this time I'm not going to
think about it until then but this is
when I'm going to schedule thinking
about it and so that's like I think a
version that works for me of what your
CFO kind of did and I'll put it in my
calendar it's like and then I can't talk
I'm like I can't talk for the next hour
I have to think about this thing busy
worrying yeah I'm busy worrying or I'm
busy doing my pro and con list but
instead of just constantly worrying
about five or six different things all
the time I will schedule it and that
really helps and then I now schedule
processing because like there are times
where you look back you're like why did
I say yes to that what was I thinking oh
I just automatically said yes I just
went into my default software you know
like which we do it's like you move into
a new house like you're going to drive
to your old house for the F for like a
couple months just for like habit you
know so to me yes I have the if it's not
a hell yes it's a no I have like posted
it's all over my desk that are like the
answer is probably going to be but
sometimes I'll just [__] say yes and
I'm like why did I do that like and I'll
just go through I'll go through my
calendar that's a big thing is like I'll
sit down and like really get thoughtful
about my calendar and be like I need to
cut 30% of this out yeah period in the
end yeah there's a a couple of
interesting things that if you find
yourself continuing to say yes to stuff
and then when it comes around regretting
the past version of you that made future
you go to this thing when you get asked
again ask yourself if this was tomorrow
would I say yes because we you know
there's this um hyperbolic discounting
so like you1 tomorrow is worth 2020 in a
year's time in the way that we see it
and the same is kind of true with what
you're prepared to oblige yourself to go
and do it's like uh something that you'd
say no to tomorrow you feel a little bit
more okay saying yes to for six months
but I first of all take a good look at
yourself and make sure first you're not
addicted to dread which I think wow
Jesus which I believe I was right number
one and number two I would go oh well I
have nothing that
day yeah it's three and a half months
away this is better than nothing that's
what I'm saying about this plan I have
nothing that day busy addiction but why
don't I want to do nothing why am I like
I got to do this thing because otherwise
I do nothing and then oh God I'd be
alone with one of my thoughts let's just
fill it with something you know like
what are you really saying when you
agree to a plan that you don't want to
do or you're kind of like ah about like
I'll do it like how little do you
respect yourself and how little do you
respect your time you know that you're
saying yes to that like I really had to
look at that and then I didn't go like
well by then and then the lack of faith
in yourself like what if I have a person
by then what if I'm going to need to be
making dinner for my guy that or going
to the farmers market that day like I
need to hold that day because what I'm
saying is my life's not going to be any
better by this day and the best I can do
is this [__] thing where I don't even
really want to do it like what a what a
wildly um self-destructive instinct what
a
sloppy you know Death By A Thousand Cuts
of just fill your life until you die how
do you think you're going to get on
given that you're going to have to take
a a pretty big baby Hiatus you know it
seems like your the Cascade of hormones
is manipulated you appropriately but I
said I feel like I've been like making
no sense during this interview I feel
like I've dude I have really really
really enjoyed this I think this is like
the first time I've been like I think I
have Mom brain like a couple times we're
talking I'm like wait what was the
question like I feel like I must sound
like I've really I've really really
enjoyed this I think it's very surpris
I've watched a good bit of your stuff
but this is a side of VI that I think is
is like really really useful
for there are a lot of things that I and
I did not want to come on your podcast
and waste your time and your and your
listeners time obviously I'm like a fan
um but there are a lot of things I said
on here that I have not said before or
even articulated out loud so I do find
myself being like being a little bit
wobbly I'm just I'm just your new
therapist so yeah take me through you
know you've got this 3 weeks pop and
then you for all the bus and all the
rest of it have you considered what
you're going to do when the like work
demon arises in the back of your mind
it's like oh like [__] he's asleep
like let's see what emails I can blah
blah as opposed to just are you how you
how do you think you're going to won't
do it I mean it's I just my that's a
form of alcoholism and that's what my
parents did to me you know and I just
like won't let it happen I have
basically six months I'm taking down
from touring um entirely and you know
for me it's it's actually really helped
me to talk to people who have had kids
again it's like the be regular and
orderly in your personal life so you can
be brave and violent in your
professional life some of the people I
admire the most have kids and they got
better creativ it's not why I'm having
them but I really just stay focused
that's [__] productiv Purgatory it's
pregnancy Purgatory I was like running
out of jokes about being single guys I'm
going to get a new hour out of this but
but you know Donald Glover for example
you know I'm sure Donald Glover
brilliant we used to tour together and
he was always a great standup I was
always a great musician and then one day
you know he makes Atlanta I'm watching
Atlanta I'm like this one of the best
shows I've ever seen and then he you
know is on Fallon um singing red bone
someone sends me the link to him S I
thought it was Marvin Gay and I call him
I'm like dude what happened is this that
or all like what are we doing like oh I
had a kid and I was like he was like it
just took my creativity performance in h
that no one ever yeah I know exactly so
it's like I he's like it just took me to
another level creatively you know so you
know I was talking to a friend the other
day who was like let it change you and
so to me it's like I think my role is to
just let it change me and to be the mom
that I didn't get to have and you know
there's all this I think sort of healing
um Dynamics around you know being able
to have the redo your childhood here
here's one thing maybe that res might
resonate with some people certainly
resonates at least in part with me which
is let's say that you've gone from a
type of person that you once are proud
of or
weren't so happy with and you've worked
quite hard to get yourself to the stage
where you are someone that you think is
more aligned existentially all the rest
of it you're speaking your locost
forward but when another set of changes
comes along there is maybe even a bit
more resistance because now you got
something to lose yes previously you
were a piece of [__] that didn't
understand the world whereas now look
I've already I've found some degree of
Safety and Security and certainty and
understanding in this me yeah but
letting go of this this me to get onto
that this me is like oh my God like
that's that type of evolution is even
harder because the bank account isn't
empty that's right that's right and I
think for me it's like you know I uh
want my kid to be proud to for me to be
his mom you know it's gonna make me cry
and so that's how I think now and it's
kind of cool you know and I found myself
even in this interview being like Oh
what if your kids watches this one day
you know it's a kind of it's made me
stutter and be a little bit you know um
I'll get used to it but I like that
directive I like that you know what's
when your kid is 10 15 whatever in
school are they going to be like Whitney
Cummings is your mom or they're going to
be like Whitney Cummings is your mom
like I want the second one yeah you know
so it's I feel like I've been kind of
floating through space for a while been
like well this makes people laugh and
this makes people laugh and like they
bought that and they bought this special
but I'm kind of like is my 15-year-old
going to be proud that I'm his mom
that's [__] cool that's really
helping me make decisions uh am going on
tour next week for the first time
ever I know this will be out after the
tour so for the people that all thank
you for coming um what are the dos and
don'ts of surviving on the
road okay the does the women in the
lobby no Lobby
no the red flag waiting in the lob the
dos and don'ts I would say make sure I
mean I'm going to get really technical
sorry too the music that is playing when
they're loading in is the show starts as
soon as they walk in the theater you
know the way you want them to feel the
music you're going to be playing when
they come in or are you playing videos
of you you know so that when they're
coming in they get to see you doing
outakes they get to see you doing stuff
the experience starts because they're
going to be you know sitting in those
seats for 30 40 minutes before you
actually come out there so I that's
always something that I feel the need to
say because the show starts before you
come out at all um I also think um being
able to uh move around on stage like are
you doing do a handheld or you doing
like a uh yeah a headset mic pretty big
pretty big stages so I should be able to
bounce around Le you done the Leicester
Square theater in the UK
huh yes I have yeah so I got Saturday
Sunday next next weekend there that'll
be fun wow that's incredible I would go
out and do the sound check like you know
go out test the lighting see it I mean
I've seen the way that you operate
before you go on like you'll be fully
prepared um but uh is you're going to be
just like doing you going to talk to the
audience at all uh yeah there'll be a
Q&A at the end so it's 45 minutes
interval 45 minutes Q&A it's solo and
there's bits and I've been working this
out I haven't really told we we
announced it and sold the tickets but we
haven't really like spoken about this
I've been doing work in progress shows
in Austin for the last two months cool
East Austin comedy club so I've done
like this routine I've done five times
now and we've got rid of stuff and we've
written it extrait you send me a
recording I want to listen to it yeah
I've got it like like that would help me
to be able to know I'll send you I'll
send you the stuff there's some [__]
mon bits in there there was one there's
one bit that everybody will hear um that
the timing of it I had to get Ryan long
to like explain the comedic timing of
how I could make it work really [__]
great but it's super I felt it was comp
I'm sure it' be like walk in the park
for you um okay so by the way if it goes
sideways just go you know what I'm
saying because then the audience gets to
see something go sideways and that's
even cooler sometimes that's funny too
do you know what I mean what about
here's one question I've got for you how
do you wind down after you've done
something uh emotionally agitating I
this would be useful for people that
have got a big job interview but it's
also useful for me after I step out on
stage in front of we're doing 1 and a
half thousand people in Dubai in two
weeks time crazy um so I'm going to have
to but I want to go to bed because I
need to be up the next day to get ready
for the next thing right so how do you
get rid of the agitation this is going
to be a hot take I say enjoy it till
you're tired you know it's youve worked
so hard this is shocking to me is that
I'm like I I'm literally I I this is
they I got the new phone I usually if
you just turn the ringer off it's off I
know what's happening power moves I I
just go to sleep when I'm tired I know
that's a really hot take I used to take
Lunesta and then I would take smoke weed
it's like a sleeping amb or whatever
yeah it's ambient is I can't believe
that shit's legal Luna is like a little
more I had my first ambient a couple of
weeks ago on how was it I was I was on a
plane I asked the first question I asked
is this going to make me start tweeting
racist
[__] you didn't could you imagine could
you imagine if I'm you know that I was
working on Roseanne at the time that I
didn't but if I'd been ambient I 100%
would have been rosan bar your new
[__] partnership like let's make
let's break the internet let's break the
internet with this partnership could you
imagine that ambian would just go down
as the most legendary [__] the fact
that like [__] racist tablets
like the racist films are you finding
yourself being too un bigoted take an
ambient and a couple of glasses of wine
biting your tongue we got you yeah want
to get fired from that job and don't
know how want to get Uninvited from
Christmas with your family I mean I but
it's I mean I took uh ambian once and I
woke up the next morning and he there
was a chicken carcass on my dining room
I had eaten an entire rotisserie chicken
and no recollection whatsoever like had
Cuts in my mouth it's monstrous that
shit's wild but I would like try to
sedate myself and I would kind of like I
think something that happens when you
get
successful is you start trying to get it
over with yes this is what you got here
this is it you're here really great
Point you're here you come off stage
it's like talk to the audience go to the
meet and GRE like feel it high five your
boys that's it because that's a form of
gratitude and it's like you know telling
I know this is going to sound like
whatever dumb or Abraham Hicks or the
secret or whatever but it's like when
you're feeling the feelings you want to
keep feeling don't try to stop feeling
them it's like your brain needs to start
practicing that Elation of like this is
my new normal is that I just did this
amazing thing thing and people loved it
and I just people just paid money to see
me talk like this is what I've been
working towards then I see people like
well how do I get to bed I'm like sleep
get to bed sleep tomorrow like you'll
sleep when you sleep you know I know as
a high performers we all have to like
sleep eight hours and see the Sun at
this amount of time but every now and
then you got to just like celebrate
that's a really really like fantastic
Point there's this I always use this
example but uh Conor McGregor fought for
the lightweight title twice maybe it's
the featherweight title twice I think it
was featherweight so the first time he
does it uh the guy that he's supposed to
fight pulls out with an injury and he
fights for the interim title against
Chad Mendes and it's a way harder fight
you remember he knocks out Aldo in 13
seconds it's that super famous knockout
and it's like everyone everyone loses
their [__] yeah yeah um but the first
time is much more of a war against Chad
Mendes and there's a lot more pressure
and so on and so forth and you know
McGregor's Also earlier in his career
and he hasn't had this first victory at
a a super high level and um he gets
interviewed in between the first interim
title success and then the subsequent uh
like combined title success or whatever
against Aldo he's like what are you
going to do differently this time as
part of your preparation process and he
says this time I'm going to enjoy it and
there's this really famous photo of him
standing like that he's got that tattoo
running up the back of his neck yeah and
he's stood with his arms out in front of
the weigh-in the ceremonial weigh-in and
it's just this Arena of people that's
there for him and he said the first time
he did it he couldn't remember it
because he was just you know looking
over the shoulder of the present moment
to see what was coming next and he was
like what like what the [__] am I doing
like if I can't
stand a decade and a half rolling
sequences in some [__] gym in Dublin
iseland sleeping in the Attic of his
parents house for that moment and he's
so concerned and fearful about the next
thing that's coming that he can't even
be there the place that he meant to get
to all along yeah and which by the way
like when you get there know you're
there you know and I'm sure that that
part of his brain is why he's who he is
and we're both like that you know what's
next what's next but I think celebration
is a form of gratitude and it took me so
long to be able to just enjoy the like
this was this was literally my dream
growing up and I'm here and I'm just
like okay well does anyone have a ban
drill cuz I need to get to bed cuz I
have this other I to get to the airport
tomorrow I'm like you know so I think
it's like every now and then we got to
just go like we like we did it you know
I think it's um it trains our brain uh I
think to be in that space more prepares
us for more of that cuz then you're kind
of like but how many how many like you
know situations does this happen and you
spend so long searching on auto trader
for the car that you want to buy and you
go to the dealership and you test all of
the different versions and you realize
it's that kind of trim that you want
into the Alcantara not the leather seats
and you want to get it with the red trim
on the steering wheel not the plane and
you want to get the this and then you
finally get it and the first thing that
you start thinking about is like what's
the next thing you're already this
amazing story from Morgan housel great
writer fantastic new book everyone needs
to go and buy it same as ever it's
available now and he he told me the
story he'd been planning this holiday
with his family for ages and he's a busy
guy and he owns a fund and he does he's
an author and he does all this other
[__] and he finally gets there and one
of the first thoughts he had on the
first night he's there on the balcony
and they planned for ages and the
family's there and they've got everyone
and has been for kids and all the rest
of the stuff and one of his first
thoughts he stood on the balcony was wow
it would be so great if we came back
next year like this would be so great if
we came back next year so even during
the experience of experiencing he was
already trying to get the anticipation
in again that's I have the same exact
story I'm at a hotel at a wedding with
my girlfriend Dory and I was like this
place would be great to like come like
spend a weekend and she was like that's
what we're doing and I was like oh like
didn't even dawn on me that I was in in
that moment and I think something that
it again little aphorisms adages little
cute little things help me sometimes it
is my goal in life to not be a sore
winner and I see a lot of sore winners
what's a sore winner a sore winner is
someone who's won they got everything
they wanted and they're like all right
we're going to get back to the hotel and
and you're like we're here yeah it's
like joyless Joy you won no when you've
won even if it's a little micro win if
you just had that great date and it
might not end in marriage or but just
like enjoy that feel those feelings
because it teaches your brain to keep
feeling those feelings there's a book
called hardwiring Happiness by Rick
Hansen which is precisely about that
they that's the smarter person that'll
say it in a more elegant way than I'm
trying to say neurons that F together
why together train your brain for
happiness because we're kind of like oh
if I just do this thing then I'll be
happy and then you do the thing and
you're like well now I need to do
another one to be happy and it's one too
many a million not enough and you're
like well that's when the difference
between it's is it a goal or is it an
addiction yeah well I mean you know how
many things have you done that you said
would make you happy one of my friends
Alex hosi has this [__] monster quote
where he says you've already achieved
the goals you said would make you
happy get [__] dude get [__] saying
that me
now now it's your excuse you said that
the next car that you would buy would
make you happy in your happiness
evaporated you said that the next house
you would buy would make you happy in
your happiness evaporated you said that
becoming a moderator on the hustlers
University Discord would make you happy
and your dad took away your credit card
right like so I would say like to calm
down after your show like tell everyone
at the theater hey I'm going to this bar
after and like chill out and just get
you might only be able to say for 10
minutes because you're going to be
getting mobbed and it's going to be
chaos but to just like show up and see
how much joy like to see the people you
know in person that you're affecting
every day like that that's another level
of euphoria one thing that kind of come
up a little bit through this
conversation sorry really quick I don't
want to interrupt you people can go oh
I'm going to listen to him at the gym
and when they get in their cars and book
a babysitter and buy tickets and show up
like these are like the fan fans and
these are like your F like you started a
cult sorry and you're about to meet your
like that that's one of the greatest
it's interesting because I've got an all
white robe and I've got this long wig of
hair that I'm going to these are people
that have been listening to you talk for
four hours a week yeah do you know what
I mean but then the ones that show up in
person there's nothing like that feeling
when you get to meet them a couple might
try to kill you but you're you're very
strong you'll be fine I didn't want to
interrupt you but no not at all uh yeah
one of the things that's come up in like
throughout this conversation is kind of
uh not feeling feelings or the aversion
to emotions arising yeah and uh do you
know what the Overton window is it's
like the window of acceptable speech so
if you imagine um from not to 100 uh all
of the things that you could say right
from the most reprehensible in one way
to the most reprehensible in another
then the over window kind of describes
this inter quartile range within that
yeah which uh is acceptable speech and
if you stray outside of that uh then
it's like unspeakable so for instance uh
saying the word [__] right is like
right on the [__] border I guess I've
just pushed the window I okay I'm
comedian you get to St all the time
we're a little off yeah um but you know
there's and that's slowly squeezes in
but I always think about that as like
okay so n to 100 are from the worst to
the best emotions that you can
experience and it feels to me like that
inter quile range is getting really
really squeezed because people are able
to you know sedate themselves from
feeling feelings even through their
phone you know I've got friends who if
they're having a bad time their coping
strategy is to just open their phone and
distract themselves by scrolling you
know that'll get you away from your
feelings and it's strange you
know the desire or the
innate tendency that we have to NE good
feelings it's like this is just an
intense feeling and I don't like it
because I am I I spend almost all of my
time in this [__] pod bleeping away
and Uber eating food to me therefore
anything of intensity just feels alien
so I'm going to I must new to this I
must hide away I always like to say to
myself never miss the opportunity to
feel a feeling that's going to motivate
you to do something great like never
never miss out on that feeling you know
whether it's you know something you
don't want to feel like jealousy or hurt
or pain or something like that like
those can be transmogrified into great
things like I mean I look at most things
I've ever done and they've come from
kind of gross feelings of wanting to get
out of a feeling or you know having gone
through pain or having to need to prove
someone wrong or try to get someone's
attention like you know to me I kind of
try to look at feelings just as
motivation for the most part to make a
better choice so if I'm constantly
anesthetizing myself I'm missing out on
that fuel to do something you know and
so that's how I try to look at it you
know and then I go like okay I want to
look at my phone right now and I want to
anesthetize and I want to check out even
though to me I mean it's playing the
slot machine it's really what you're
doing it's a gambling addiction at the
end of the day right you're playing for
that one dopamine hit you got that one
time when that one girl made that
comment that you liked you know whatever
it's all just [__] you know from
then on out trying to achieve that same
level of dopamine it seems like but I go
like is it worth the shame I'm going to
feel in 20 minutes when I have just been
on Instagram for you know what I mean
it's just not worth like I know how this
story ends so I'm able to kind of walk
myself through it and be like I'd rather
feel this feeling of right now than
shame in 20 minutes I've got this bit
that uh appears in the live show where I
I talk about the story that you tell
yourselves about the decisions that you
made last for far longer than the impact
of the decisions so you being the sort
of person who eats a cookie like yeah
there's calories in the cookie and
you'll feel nice and then like you might
be a bit fatter tomorrow or whatever but
the story that you tell yourself about
being the sort of person who is or is
not a cookie eater basically lasts for
the rest of your life that's it and I
and I don't have willpower and I'm just
going to eat the cookie anyway and why
you know so to me it's like I can really
you know and this is something that we
you know talk about in program is every
year that you're in this 12-step program
you get to have a second of pause you
know so it's sort of like I've been in
for you know almost 10 years now so I
have 10 seconds of pause before I you
know I like to respond and not react is
the goal you know it's like I want to
pick up my phone it's like I have 10
seconds to go like is this a negative
contribution to My Future Self is this I
know how this story ends is this really
seems like you've done the work really
really does seem like you've done the
work even if inwardly it feels like
you're just a catastrophe that doesn't
have their [__] together well to me I
like to like just say that to people you
know and just share that on podcast so
because I think people would probably
think like oh look she's achieved all
this stuff and I like to go like I've
had to struggle with all this stuff you
know no it really does seem like you've
done the work I've been very very
impressed with you today oh gosh crazy
impressed I feel like I've been like
sort of rambly and confusing and not
been very very incisive where should
people go they want to check out more of
your [__] and you're going to be absent
from the road for at least six months so
I am I my six special um just came out
it's on ofv
of.tv Whitney amazing totally uncensored
and totally free and what else what else
is what else is happening what else
Whitney Cummings my podcast is good for
you that's it I'm embarrassed to promote
myself I'm not good at it if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe